all right and we are live the last word
lord cognito ibontas thai guy travis
that thursday evening campfire that i
love
what's going on gents e start with you
first how's life man what's been going
on with you man that's pretty good
computer is dry so that's always a good
thing
you scared us for a minute bro
i'm lucky enough to be able to make
jokes i got i gotta throw them out there
um can someone in the community make
that uh that uh call of duty modern
warfare hey no russian meme where
they're in the elevator can we do it
except for hey no spills can somebody
make that and just post it every time
eve promotes the show just take it
spills you know
so yeah i'm doing pretty good just had a
little bit of dinner i think we're all
kind of settling in um
but so far pretty chill i'm literally
like trying to figure out like video
organization because i want to jump into
guardians because
more and more people i know like a buddy
of mine who like doesn't usually like
will usually skip the stories actually
enjoying guardians so it's like that's
kind of the one that's on my radar and
you know can assume where things are
coming but that's that's my next if i
can squeeze it in but for now that's
kind of where i'm at travis what are you
playing reviewing or trying to squeak in
a match or two of destiny if you can
yeah actually
crazy story this week not a crazy story
but it unexpected news is that i played
um a ton of destiny this past weekend
because i finally
got my girlfriend to play through uh
forsaken with me
before it goes away so we played through
all forsaken
and here's the kicker she liked forsaken
a lot and is now hooked on destiny
and it's like like playing it when i'm
not playing it like yeah i'm gonna walk
out of destiny real quick and i'm like
oh man this is the start of something
dangerous
actually her gamer tag is thai girl
travis that's right
either travis does different things on
the week he'd rather travis has a
different job on the weekends before
it's his girlfriend
oh you biting you're zuckerberging
oh i sound bad to you guys
oh it kind of bursts a little bit better
first
i think it's good now i think it's good
talking
test test yeah yeah you're back yeah
you're good you're good you're back um
so i actually did all of my uh my um
grinding for festival of the lost i'm
now completely done with that event
i caught up on some you know like
seasonal artifact or not seasonal
artifact uh
seasonal um
the weapon ornaments weapons
missions and stuff like that i've
actually played a ton of gambit and
strikes which
you will be surprised to hear from me um
so yeah it was a very productive destiny
week for me but aside from that
i finished my review of my previous game
this week i'm working on
writer's republic the ubisoft extreme
sports open world game which is
basically kind of like a forza horizon
clone yeah but it's quite good um and
then i also finished in one day
the guardians of the galaxy game oh wow
which is like a pretty long game but i
just i binged that thing dude i really
liked that game it was uh to me it's
like the sleeper hit of 2021 like that's
what everything lots of people for
whatever reason were expecting that game
to not be great but it was
i i couldn't put it down i really really
enjoyed it i think other people should
play that game so yeah
i was like and i think the thing at
least from what i saw from guardians of
the galaxy still holds true from pretty
much most of the reviews is that combat
is fine
from what i've gathered it doesn't like
it didn't bother me i was like
but i was like when i saw it before it
just seemed kind of like um okay like it
and again from what i saw that's like
it is the better than the you know it's
the sum of its parts are better than the
pieces like from whenever the story the
art and all that stuff like really
really good pieces combat is
not the highest piece of the puzzle is
the best way i can phrase that so that
that still holds up to what i saw but
like the fact that people are raving
about everything else still makes it
worth it it sounds like
so so the like the combat thing to me
that this game really reminds me of um
uncharted 3 right where it's really
about like it's about like the energy
and the story and the comedy and the
characters and you're having fun while
you're playing it even when the combat
isn't that good and i would describe the
combat in uncharted 3 as not being
particularly good but it serves the
purpose it has that energy of like
silliness and goofiness while you're
doing it and you're kind of just like oh
you know it doesn't matter if the
shooting's a little sloppy like the
characters are talking and the banter
and action and stuff like that and so um
the combat in guardians of the galaxy
isn't like
amazing where you're like oh my god this
best thing ever but it's so silly and
the characters are talking throughout it
that i didn't even really notice the
combat i was just sort of like having
fun in it and you do these team huddles
where you get the team to come together
and then you play a song on your uh your
oh my god you're really going into this
music plays during the time i've heard
those are terrible
yeah all your characters are more
powerful while you're uh as long as the
song lasts so they're going by
rules i guess
one song
but yeah
[Laughter]
big good man besides popping up on that
live show
yeah man i've been you know hitting it
up um a little still on my destiny
vacation outside of trials i've been i'm
on my vacation still so it's all disco
elysium all day every day
and i'm thoroughly addicted to that it
scratches my detective need he's
literally the worst detective ever and i
love it it's fun i'm learning he's
learning about himself why he's learned
trying to do a case i highly recommend
it it's the funniest game i'm thoroughly
entertained with this game i got about
maybe i've been blazing about like 15-20
hours already nice and i just can't wait
to get back into it you did a custom
build so is your character
kind of stupid
no he's actually a very intellectually
sh and strong guy but
his motorics are terrible his motorists
are terrible
he's like a clumsy he's like mr magoo
yeah yeah he's just that kind of thing
but he's very precise i can visualize
certain things and stuff like that but
it's really good a lot of hardcore rpg
uh things on checks and stuff like that
i love it man you were sorry cop
um
i think it's superstar cop i think i'm
leaning into um
artsy cop or something something like
something like about arts or something
yeah cause i'm like running around on
walls painting stuff i'm doing all type
of crazy stuff the thing i love about
that game is anyone you talk to they
have completely different like
experiences like one guy like one guy i
play
who played that game told me he just did
like a full strength and motor like
it was just the stupidest cop ever and
apparently that way of playing the game
is one of the one of the best ways
to do it idiot yeah full like brawn
idiot um but yeah i i'm i need to get
back to playing it but yeah i love that
game so fully voice acted excellent game
but uh enough for me we got like this uh
very patient and spiritual patient
that's been here that we got to bring in
right
hold on man
stream probably just oh
i have no idea what's going on like you
want to move the uh discord server maybe
maybe no you guys are mostly fine
it's just like connecting to youtube for
me tonight it's it's my upload speed and
i'm still fighting with it there's like
an issue that's going on i've had text
out multiple times again
um it's back it's bad yeah it's back so
we're gonna get it going um well i wanna
at least make sure everybody could hear
this thing so no here we go
welcome to the last word number 171 as
our time with purple pumpkins and spooky
sounds are coming to an end it wouldn't
be right to leave without the ever
evolving meta being in the discussion
we just wrapped up another experiment
with saint 14 and we're all a bit
curious where the dust will settle with
osiris quiet times may be coming for the
next month in destiny but we aren't too
far away from a pirate's booty and the
return of the og exotic drop
our guest this week has seen the ebbs
and flows of this universe we are all
wrapped up in for quite some time now
but the controller was in his hand for
many years
while his time as a rodent on
playstation got him started started
adventure is what really called his name
and exploring what the world has to
offer really doesn't seem to be his
nature taking a chance trying something
new isn't ever easy but as the tides can
change this man is willing to move with
them taking his sex success of embracing
memes and now making a career out of it
i have enjoyed this man's journey
through the internet also i almost
forgot please send all things tank
related to his twitter handle
so let's welcome the community manager
for poorly timed games also community
manager and writer for the destiny
tracker website a man with phil spencer
on his friends list and recent fire team
member who is waiting for benji to stop
tweeting about is luna
the boss of the inverted spire strike a
modular mind of the vex and the only
boss who has ever been called swole in
destiny the one the only prothean how
are you doing sir
that might have been like the best intro
i've ever received in my entire life
that was amazing we we try so we are
very happy to have you how have you been
what you been up to what are you doing
you've been busy i know that so yeah
i've been good um you know all
year really i've kind of just you know
with covid you know just hanging out at
home
doing stuff while i can trying to stay
busy but past few months i've been
extremely busy
i recently got
promoted at destiny tracker as a writer
and kind of working more with the
community on that side and i've been
having a good time doing that and
two weeks ago yeah two weeks ago a
little over two weeks ago i um received
a
position at poorly timed games which is
a game studio making a new game called
grim tranquility the ceo of the company
actually worked at bungie his name was
cr is chris wright
and uh
it's it's been a quite quite a fun
experience doing that and uh my life has
gotten very busy the past two weeks but
i'm i'm really grateful for it
that's awesome man
well we're definitely happy to have you
but we got to get to know you a little
bit so as i mentioned kind of
you're get you've been gaming for a
while i don't exactly know how old you
are but certain you know mascots
definitely bring up a little bit of age
so i know you've been around the block
for gaming but what are your like
major stanza outs in gaming for your
gaming history things that got you
hooked things that have a special place
just you know what are the big points i
mean outside of our big topic in game of
discussion but like what are
what are the games that make you who you
are
yeah so i mean i've been playing
video games ever since i was a little
kid but like the first one that really
stuck with me was halo 2 halo 3. um
i didn't have an xbox at the time but i
would go to
friends houses and we would play halo
all day oh we would repeat story
missions
uh do multiplayer online everything um
and then i got an xbox i think 2010
which is when halo reach came out
and i still think that is the game with
most hours
i think it's still more than destiny i
think destiny's coming close but
i
i was in halo
every day
making maps and forge custom games nice
i would
i would do the campaign on easy and then
medium and then hard and then legendary
and i'm like all right let's do that
again
are you bungie simp you i know i am a
bungie
100 love it love it man tremendous
tremendous so it's like yes so yeah i'm
sorry
yeah so i mean when uh because i am a
bungee simp when uh they announced that
they were making destiny i was like
i have to try that right and it's kind
of been destiny ever since i've been
experimenting with more games here and
there but
i still consider myself like a destiny
main like playing wise so
no doubt no doubt yeah i was gonna ask
you because um obviously you know the
halo in the in the first person
it's like the natural transition right
you know for for guys to go into destiny
but you also have you know what i
consider that like single player
background as well you have this unique
combination of loving single-player
games you know what are some of those
type of single-player titles that really
kind of got your heartstrings and into
gaming and loving that genre
yeah so um
the actually the telltale walking dead
series i really enjoyed um it was
it didn't like look the best
yeah yeah i i don't even know it just
wasn't the greatest it wasn't the
greatest but the stories
yeah the story was
yeah it was so indeed
it was amazing oh that game made me cry
i think that was like the first game
that made me cry the story would lead at
the end
that got me man that guy that was tough
that was a tough the clementine and lee
story i agree i agree
just that's the country but it's just
like it's one of those things that
you could tell they they it was new the
genre was new right but they kind of hit
a gold mine and then they kind of set
off a whole chain of games because of it
but i do agree with you i think that was
kind of like the key as far as really
putting them on the map i agree with you
big time on that story yes i was kind of
mastering them all by the way all those
scenes yes they did
i i haven't i'm planning on playing it
through again but i need to be like
emotionally stable if i want to be there
i'll be honest
so what other single player games you
get
yeah so also red dead redemption i
really enjoyed mass effect um
which
[Music]
access to the last word and you picked
the right one this is a man of culture
do you understand this did you
understand please tell the people yes
please tell the people why mass effect 2
is your favorite fact i must hear this
preach the gospel sir
honestly
the gameplay was pretty good but the
story is just incredible
it's just an incredible story
from beginning to end
fair enough fair enough right man
suicide mission baby
yeah um
yeah for sure more single-player games
recently um star wars jedi fallen order
i love
so good
yeah
very underrated it came out late 2019
right yeah i like missed the game awards
game awards and stuff like that and it
should have been in there and people
forgot about it yep yeah i was like and
stuff like that that happens it's never
going to get in the next year it's like
too far gone but you know i have a
theory though i think they did it on
purpose i i think there's games now that
as a tactic avoid the
the award season so that they don't have
to get caught up in that and one one
example of it this year halo infinite
after the awards because it's a
lose-lose if halo infinite doesn't win
game of the year people are like oh
halo's a failure it wasn't game of the
year right but if they can just avoid
that conversation altogether then i
think they win and i i honestly think
it's a
part of their decision
interesting
yeah i doubt that really goes big into
release date choices but you know
conspiracy theories are fun i bet you
it's part of it like i bet you some
games playing around with like his
conspiracy theories i was gonna say when
it comes to like the financial decisions
and all the other things that go in if
it's in there it is the smallest piece
of any pie it's just a guess what i
think my game awards i don't think
should choose when halo is going to get
really
phil spencer's like hold on uh excuse me
jeff
jeff wins wins the game awards i want to
be the day after just to clarify
there's this 20th anniversary and
everything else that's not important but
jeff keely we gotta we gotta square this
away
i don't think it's the game awards it's
controlling the narrative on the
marketing side and part of that
narrative is like the game of the year
discussions that's like a huge part of
the year and i think that that the
industry is starting to like recognize
that and so there's like this window in
december after nominations are over
where you can sort of slip by that
conversation so i think the marketing
team has more power than you you might
think and
you can bet that they're looking at
things like metacritic and and the game
awards and how that affects their
narrative of whether they're winning or
losing and halo has such like an
incredibly high bar i think that if
there's any any game that's like looking
at that sort of stuff and figuring out
how they can
you know not have the highest
expectations ever but so as a big halo
fan senor protheon
how is everything shaping up as of late
are you
are you on the hype train full bore is
is anything is anything question marks
are you just like 10 out of 10 let's do
this
so when the first game gameplay
trailer whatever that was showcased last
year
yeah i was like
yeah this looks fun like obviously the
art didn't look great but i was like
it's halo i i just want a new halo so i
was alright with it already yeah and
then they said they were delaying it and
i'm like okay that just put the
expectations from here to here right if
they're gonna delay it by over a year
then
now my expectations are pretty high and
when i played the beta um i had an
absolute blast and i cannot wait for
that
yeah
all right
let's go that sort of tour i do wanna i
was like so i do wanna ask one question
for all three on here because i know all
three of you are much bigger halo people
than i am
campaign
trailer dropped about six minutes got to
see some stuff um as for
the big question i would say the kind of
like question marks i've seen from one
or two places
the outpost open world system do you
guys think it will
land do you guys think
what do you think that's kind of that's
a question i'm curious the big fans i'm
curious your thoughts on let's get our
esteemed guest first
yes
pro do you know what you thinking man
halo
so i actually have a quick question is
this like confirmed that it's only going
to be these outpost type missions or do
we still not know no
no because my theory is that there's not
going to be the outpost mission yeah
they're still not holding a lot it feels
like good to you my theory is that like
they're still like the core of halo are
like those long
lengthy missions that have like a very
certain structure
i feel like that's still going to be in
the game and that these this open world
aspect is just going to be more so in
addition to that
that's my theory like say a campaign
mission you go from point a to point b
now you unlock extra missions in point b
but there's still a story line from b to
c if that makes sense okay i think i've
seen it that's kind of my theory i'm
down with it um i i trust 343 industries
to try something new um
i am i skeptical yeah but
i'm still down nice not afraid i found
this i'm jumping
no no no no
travis just said yes so you may have had
this already
yeah no that's cool i mean you know me
and maddie talked about it and um
it's weird because i'm
in this weird mindset where i have like
open world game fatigue
but with halo i'm like i've never seen
halo like this you know
and there is a part of me that
you know i agree with proteon in the
sense that i think that you know there
may be a nice hopefully a healthy
balance of you know going through the
map shout out to the cops coming by
going to the map and everything and um
seeing what's going on my concern is
different microsoft actually is not the
outposting my concern is more of the
biome thing i want to see
more diverse areas i'm not saying
they're not they don't exist but like
let's say they had a snow area or they
had a deserted area i don't i don't want
the whole thing to just be you know
jungle outside kind of cool ring for
drive or force you know i mean now i did
hear there are different things i hear i
hear you go down in caves or just you
know different stuff so it probably will
be and if there's not an abundance of
the volumes my other theory is that
because it's kind of following
pseudo destiny with you know live
service kind of like ongoing 10-year
plan game that my guess is they will add
their europa
you know
they're you know because we're from
destiny we know how that goes with
future content and stuff like that but
no i'm excited i think it's um it's halo
the sandbox is amazing the things you
can do looks so fun the grappling hook
and for me personally the only thing
from halo 5 that i missed
was the thrust
and when i saw the thrusters
as a customer so now yeah bro so i love
the idea of a customizable master chief
that excites me on even if it's on my
new level but charles what you think
after everything you saw like how you at
this thing man yeah i i think um people
are being really pessimistic about this
and i think just generally speaking my
reaction is people are just not
halo's like a it's a sacred cow right
like a lot of people have a hard time
talking about babies
but personally my opinion when i saw it
was i thought it's brilliant and that
343 is way ahead of where other people
are and i i don't think people
understand what they're trying to do yet
because for me
that moment where you touch down on the
halo ring and combat evolved and you
just you open up that kind of semi-open
world on that first level that was that
was so informative i feel like my brain
like
gained so many wrinkles on that day
because it kind of like changed what i
thought a game could be and i just had
so much fun even though it was only
those three little areas you go to and
you take them out but like it kind of it
kind of like opened up this idea of like
what gaming can be and i think they're
embracing that they've said that this is
like a soft reboot and i think an idea
where you're on a halo ring and you're
just exploring and doing stuff and then
in between that you have main kind of
missions yeah like that that's that's
like
me what they should have been doing at
like halo 4 right and halo games have
have become more and more linear over
time like if you go back and you play
combat of all two betrayals that level
is crazy like the amount of stuff you
can do and places you can go and over
the years they've gotten more and more
kind of just like shooter hallways like
call of duty right
halo 4 is the worst one in terms of like
how much it just limits where you can go
and what you can do and focuses you on
the campaign i think they're trying to
do the opposite to that i think people
who compare it to like far cry are
completely missing the fact that like
this is a halo game like far cry's
biggest problem is that the gun gunplay
has never been amazing right like
it's sort of just like a generic shooter
and its advantage is that it's over the
top and has an open world halo is
is on a whole different level and if
they could turn that into a semi-open
world game with uh side quests and all
that and rpg elements like you said cog
i think that that's like that will turn
out to be like the breath of the wild of
the halo series i think people will be
like wow why wasn't halo like this
youtuber
yeah why didn't they do this so long ago
and and the other thing is that we
already know there's going to be
multiple campaigns inside halo infinite
because they've said it before there's
already two campaigns long multiple year
plans like it sounded like they said 10
years ago oh god
yeah two of them
have sort of been two of them have sort
of been leaked already but it's not to
the extent extent of of uh destiny you
know destiny tries to confine it all
halo is going to have the campaign
ongoing and then a separate app that's
the multiplayer and they don't really
compete with each other but i have a ton
of thoughts on these i'm actually going
to be talking about i'm going to be
doing like a halo uh podcast with uh
aims with it oh yeah
i got to listen what y'all doing is so
awkward
yeah he's very hardcore i love ainsley
yeah you two would make a great
so we're definitely going to be talking
about this but i'm like super passionate
that this is the right way for halo to
be going and i i think people don't get
it yet and i think it'll take them a
while to catch up but i think once they
get the game in the hands there's
there's a pretty good chance that
they're they're just going to nail this
thing and everybody's going to be like
damn yep just wait five years ago just
wait five years from now when they make
the halo content vault and twitter goes
crazy
yo
here's the thing uh protheon halo
already has a content ball it's called
you're right you're right
if they move the old campaigns and throw
them in master chief collection and that
just becomes a 200 gigabyte game i have
no problem with that keep it going you
know what i mean so that's what destiny
needs destiny needs a destiny
uh guardian collection
uh and and just you know make all their
old campaigns available through that
sort of uh app yeah yeah
absolutely well i am so sorry i took us
down the tangent of halo but as you're a
big halo fan i did want to open it up i
just didn't know um i was going to open
it quite that wide um sorry once you
don't know
it just comes flowing through it flows
out what i wanted to ask though for you
at least for me as well um outside of
gaming
your name like your name your emblem and
everything did you
where did it where was the origination
the choice for it and then also you
gotta explain one or two of the jokes
that have happened along the way because
those are entertaining break it down
okay
super long story short right i just
wanted a gaming themed
twitter so i didn't bother my right like
real life friends right i didn't want
them to be bothered by all my posts and
all that stuff so
i saw this is way back in like 2014 2015
i saw twitter accounts that were just
like random destiny things and i'm like
sure you know so i originally named mine
quodron which is actually one of the vex
bosses and prison of elders
yes yeah and i wasn't really trying to
like
be a content creator then or anything i
just it was just the name right and then
uh fix warbot it has a ride yeah yes
exactly
that's pretty good actually
i love it the announcer would scream
things at five times the normal volume
whenever that person's show
i think it was varrix's coming out party
he became a star to me it was like what
is wrong with him
you could
all right he's about to start talking
yeah so then destiny 2 came around or
the beta came around and i saw protheon
he was inverted spider beta strike so
i'm like you know what let's just go
with the times right so i just changed
my name to that and embraced it and i
never
changed it um
and
i just
that's that's kind of how that started
um
and then the uh swotheon so there was
that bug that made protheon three times
as big yes
classic so some of the some of the
people that knew me tagged me in that
post and that's kind of where i got
started which kind of a weird way to get
started with where i am today but
he does some weird origin stories yeah
it's kind of weird that like my origin
story of where i am now is a bug in a
video game but
i mean i'll take it
i love it
yeah so i've just kind of embraced the
name and
everything about that um
and then
last year
uh like a week after beyond light came
out running some strikes getting my
power level up for the raid or whatnot
and um
i'm running the inverted spire strike
and i saw a drake tank spawn
and i've never seen that before ever
so i took a video of it i put it on
twitter and i just said hey is this is
this new like i've never seen this
before is this new with beyond light are
they just adding like tanks to strikes
and about like eight to ten people
commented like the exact same tweet that
just said no it's always been in the
game like
you're stupid like it's always about
it's just really it's just really really
rare
so i was like annoyed reading that out
because me i'm like this is what i would
do if i saw it if i saw one person like
comment that i wouldn't say anything i'm
like okay that person gets it i don't
need to comment it again
so i quoted that tweet and i said thanks
for the the 10 people who said like i
get it i didn't i didn't hear you the
first nine times
and everyone thought it'd be funny to
remind me forever for the rest of my
life that there's a tank that spawns in
the inverted spire which is ironically
the prothean strike so i still get posts
of hey the tanks spawned with
screenshots
oh they found it never petty they petty
i saw the tank today
yeah exactly october 27th as i load into
the vanguard playlist tonight she saw
the inverted spire and as i jumped off
the cliff i saw the tank below i had to
tweet protheon
now we know your uh your halloween
twitter name rare tank spawn
it's scary
it's very scary i like it
yeah so now i call myself a tank
enthusiast so
that's what's up have you driven a tank
in real life yet i think you need to do
this
no
it's on my list of things to do like
ironically i love tanks in video games
like the scorpion tank and halo not to
like reopen that can of worms but that's
right that's right reopening and you do
that you do that you do that yeah just
can't go ahead
you can have tank themed streams where
you play games that feature tanks and
you wear a tank top
you know the
possibilities
i didn't think about that i'm done with
him he's out of he's on loose right now
question
being over on the subject of takes how
did you feel
when d1 had what was it like mixed
combat arena where they had the vehicles
and like how did you feel about that d1
yeah so i mean coming from halo i was
like oh this is like big team battle and
it kind of was but kind of wasn't it was
kind of like strange like a strange in
between i do want to see it return in
some way
yeah i do want to see it return but like
in a good way like if i got if it were
to return how it was i i probably
wouldn't be happy
i don't know maybe i would because pvp
kind of needs like you need like mario
kart racing just put them together
we need diversity yeah i i actually i
had a theory that you know how we've all
uh us pvp mains [ __ ] we've been like
bemoaning when did when did destiny when
did bungie give up on pvp my theory was
they gave up on pvp as soon as they took
all the vehicles out of pvp way back in
d1 i think it's that long ago because
that was the point where like they were
like we're going to build the pvp it's
going to be like this whole thing it's
kind of going to be like a sandbox-like
halo and then they
sort of like scaled it way way yeah
and they gave up completely on the idea
of having big maps and vehicles and i
was just like oh i guess destiny isn't a
pvp game and i've i felt that way since
then like even when they added trials
and stuff i was sort of just like yeah i
mean this is nice but
pvp is sort of
the secondary in the destination i mean
look how small they scaled it in the
launch of destiny 2 4 before yes i got
really very angry at that i remember
that that was it that was the time oh
yeah oh yeah they've been scaling it
down basically from i mean they've added
modes over the years and then taking
them away which i guess they're
re-giving some of those back to us
long live rift
but yeah i i i honestly think like if if
bungie would have stuck to their guns
and tried to develop the
destiny sandbox to include vehicles and
have maps and different types of game
modes they could have a trials and then
a more casual version where it's just
big team battle vehicles and stuff the
game would be so different today
yeah yeah but yeah they've never sort of
just gave it up they just went away for
trav what you got for uh
proteon the legend here any questions
yeah i was hoping you could tell uh
people who don't know what destiny
tracker is what it is and how you got
involved in that and all that nice
yeah so um destiny tracker is a branch
of tracker network they track
millions of stats in tons of games
rocket league battlefield halo call of
duty warzone
league of legends like tons of things
and
so i i've always kind of expressed
interest publicly that like i think
being you know social media manager
um like running that stuff would be
interesting for things that i'm
passionate about
um
and i was just reached out by um his
name's jay he was like the general
manager of the destiny tracker branch
and he said hey i
would you want to help out on destiny
tracker just tweeting like
news posts and you know helping me with
the account like we've grown a lot and
we need the help so i said sure i'll try
it out and there's a lot of learning on
the way um
but it's been a really fun experience um
it's a tough it's tougher than it looks
like you're constantly scanning stuff
like destiny news and yeah you know you
want to
you want to provide information in a way
that isn't hard to read right right
because there's tons of people out there
that don't read every 12 there's tons of
people that don't read every reddit post
and you want to kind of like condense
those important points to people
um to social media which is what these
people are on but they might not be
necessarily looking
at everything destiny and not be caught
like caught up to date with the news
i mean thankfully the um
bungie's been putting like those in-game
messages out
yeah like
like i think that has been an awesome
change because there's so many like some
of my friends they don't they don't know
everything going on with destiny they're
more casual player and they don't know
all this stuff
yeah even though that's kind of how i
got started
yeah even i look at the destiny tracker
post just because sometimes it's easier
than logging on especially if i'm
working on a review or something and i
don't have a ton of time to commit to
destiny it's just good to like check in
and see what's happening
but yeah it's interesting because uh
destiny is one of those weird games
where it's like
the hardcore that are invested we know
what's going on but we even have like
it's one of these games that it kind of
requires an external resource to know
what's going on consistently you know
what i mean like it's just it's we i've
never really had a game like that where
it's like you know and there's so many
different pockets of information you can
go to specific people for so it's cool
that you know you guys kind of got
something to consolidate a lot of the
information and bring that out you know
to the people that i think that's really
cool what do you think is to add on to
travis's question like what do you think
is kind of the hardest things that like
people don't understand about that
destiny tracker that's hard to maintain
and keep up with
it's it's
definitely
scanning information 24 7.
um we'll get tweets at 12 o'clock 12
12 o'clock and three seconds right after
three seconds have to reset hey what's
the trials weapon
okay i i don't know i'm working on it
and that could be time consuming
sometimes because every you know every
friday i'm looking um scanning
there's tons of misinformation back and
forth too and we don't want to be like
we don't want to be providing that like
false information um so it's just having
to like keep your mind
um constantly looking at updates
it could get exhausting sometimes
and it's actually kind of
different like if you look at um tracker
network we're not really a news
organization we're it's purely for stats
but we kind of converted the
destiny tracker account into news
because we felt like it was just
beneficial for the community and
everyone else to kind of stay up to date
with things
yeah sorry for tweeting at you about
what the trials weapon is every friday
okay
it's just it's my ritual you know we all
have yeah
friday rituals my rituals i tweet at the
destiny tracker account and ask them for
a question i also like to ask them for
zur
where is her i asked them one hour
before zer shows up before my move yeah
if you ask them one hour before two
weeks from now you'll be right on time
that's right yeah good question that is
true
ask me how i know that
um
yeah so whenever there's like a new
thing that happens at reset jay and i
are kind of like oh boy there we go we
got to be looking every day oh we got
the ag receptor quest you've got these
like
yeah yeah
yeah
it's literally i mean i don't keep up
with everything by any mean means
especially on like an article website
you're like i'll try and do everything
you can but yeah so it's like 12 00
clock in one second go uh
help
can't even get to the right instance
you're like tweets are going you're like
i just need to log in
mm-hmm
nope it's pretty i mean
the reveal event was rough
i mean we warned everyone beforehand
we're like we're gonna try to sum up
everything so sorry for the spam but
right that event was like so fast we
were like all right i got this i got
this we like double tweeted some things
like oh i'll delete this one
so i mean that part of it can be
challenging but anyway moving on yeah
yeah you have a glaive go
you'll be able to make them maybe
the glaive they at least focused on for
like 10 seconds the weapon crafting was
the weirdest one to me because it's a
huge announcement and they spent like
half a sentence on it they're like yeah
everything's coming anyway next so same
with the void 3.0 if like i re-watched
it
it was like 20 seconds
like oh yeah we'll be working all the
light subclasses and we'll be starting
with void and the other ones will be
coming later okay bye okay whoa okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah correct they did a
little breakdown on it in one of the
twabs i remember like a bit of a
discussion we eventually got to but
i mean
going back to what you guys were talking
about
destiny has a history
of launching things
not always in the best state whether
it's currencies or convolution or
anything
when it comes to weapon crafting and
prothean you get to go first
do you have any thoughts of how it might
work and do you think it's going to be
player friendly or
not
i'll be able to tee it up for you or
anything
yeah
what no i
i'm not really used to weapon like i
don't play many games that already has
weapon crafting so i'm not really sure
what to expect and especially in
destiny with how many currencies there
are i know they mentioned you'll like
rank up your weapon like the more you
use it the more you could craft so i'm
assuming it's actually going to be more
like in destiny 1 where like you get
experience and you kind of upgrade it
yeah that's that's where i'm going going
back to the nodes
we've come full circle yep i i really do
i think we might see the overturn of the
circles ah we gonna be on the cosmodrome
with doing this the spin metal dance
they gotta find
uh environmental currency so you know
gotta gotta spend those currencies
yeah so i'm not the best on like weapon
crafting how that works um that's my
theory i'm hoping it's player friendly i
hope there's not a currency involved in
how many
do you think there will be
how many of these parts do you need to
convert into weapon
barrels and stocks to then assemble into
a weapon frames and then take to the
forge to create your actual weapon
template and then you can take that
template and go to ada and she's gotta
put it back in the loom to cover it in
fabric and then crack
and craft
but then did they simplify that though
a little bit okay they took one of them
check out the they took out one of the
steps yeah uh i would like to see a show
of hands how many people here think that
there is even a small chance who thinks
that there's like greater than a five
percent chance
that in the weapon crafting system
they include an existing material called
weapon parts
as
in the system i think there's a chance
of that they got to figure out what's
going on
i think there is a less than one percent
chance that weapons
have any role in weapon crafting i think
that's great no you don't think you will
no no oh yeah all you don't know okay
people stockpiled them too much and like
how the hell are they gonna you know
there's like no idea
budget's been known to kind of like like
think about the existence of what was
that the the
the something of triumph the callous
room where they he kind of like they
gouged us for all our resources just to
finish that trophy room remember that
that thing
and then they deleted the damn thing
after you dumped all your resources into
it they vaulted the
uh halls of what i can't remember i know
what you're talking about though you
know what i'm telling you
there's two there's two ways they do it
one is they take all of your resources
because
yeah you're thinking of is that uh the
trophy room right yeah
they sucked out all your resources to
get it that's one thing tribute we're
trying to reign in the tribute hall
tribute hall yeah they were trying to
reign in the amount of resources that
people had very clearly because they
just overcharged us for everything but
uh the
the thing about weapon parts is they're
already kind of useless right
and so
they don't really need to reduce our
amount of weapon parts but they can't
they also can't just have us have ten
thousand so many weapon parts on day one
so that means that they have to come up
with a weapon crafting system that does
not use the item called weapon parts
which is crazy like that's just like
looking at it on paper like they're
gonna have a weapon crafting system
weapon parts aren't gonna be included in
it but i just don't see a world where
they
incorporate weapon parts because it's
such a
like useless material right now and i've
i've got what about weapon telemetry
telemetry and and and 000 chance
components
a lot of people running around with the
mod
there's a lot of stuff
yeah i don't i don't think so i think
it's all new i think i think i think uh
ubantus is right on the money that's
gonna be like weapon frames and you know
weapon barrels and they're just gonna
have like all these specific parts and
the actual thing called weapon parts is
just going to be completely useless and
people are going to be looking at it
like what are all these parts that
apparently aren't
maybe they'll let you take your weapon
parts and spend like a thousand of them
to buy one weapon barrel or something
just to get rid of it and address the
the weirdness of that currency but i
just really don't see i i don't see
those being used at all and i would be
i'd be shocked if they were like oh yeah
you use weapon parts to craft weapons in
our weapon system then i'd be like they
see like
okay
they seem like they want to make weapon
crafting like a new core part of destiny
so i'm hoping it's not so convoluted and
it's more simple yes please
i know
is there going to be a crafting limit
lockout
of course
how many can you do each money on that
one yeah i'm putting money it's going to
be like a warframe where you buy it this
week you make your deposit and then
you've got to let that vested interest
grow and blossom into a weapon next week
that you pick up at at arms day they're
going to bring back arms day when you
can hey
yeah i forgot about that yeah
i could see them being like oh you need
to upgrade your weapon
it'll it it'll get to the next stage at
like reset i could see them right
something like that yeah well hopefully
it's just too hard if they put like a
cap on it or if they put like synth
weave into it or some like cap that
could be raised really hopefully
you really hope for this bungie y'all
it's budgie you know how they do
i do know how they do but so far they've
been pretty good at staying away from
stuff that is pay to win and if you put
a cap or money at all into a weapon
system then it becomes pay to win
ornaments fine but an actual weapon
system where i could have better weapons
than you because i paid money they've
never crossed that line and i think if
they did they they would have to do
180 pretty quick because no i agree i
agree that the players yeah like that
so here's the question for the honest
are you um as you've been covering a lot
of destiny now you cover for destiny
tracker
with everything you've heard speculated
thought about on your own
what are your kind of like top three
things that you're most looking forward
to want more explanation on anything
related to witch queen that is like on
your radar like as soon as hey there's
an article about this like what's your
that you're like diving into like what
what are your big things that you want
explained or you want to know more about
with regards to which queen besides
obviously what just broke down
so what i'm most excited for or what i'm
more
like like confused about either like
just some topic with regards to which
queen where you're like i need more
information good or bad like please
don't do this or i can't wait to know
about this
okay well as a
nova bomb
warlock i'm so excited for void 3.0
stand up devour and all that let's go
talk to me yeah
yeah um i mean
yeah so that's like void 3.0 i'm so
excited for like a new play style stasis
i wasn't really a fan of stasis but all
the aspects and all like
the turret that warlocks have and all
the different like customizations
for warlocks
yeah you guys got the cool stuff
yeah we did kind of get spoiled with
that yeah
that would have definitely been
contributed to why i lose it if i was
doing that
i was gonna say we won that match oh we
got stomped oh my god i was stopping
like one one round versus this yeah by
my poor little dudes and then i was like
i get this message i'm like
i said this person talking trash like i
didn't know you know you just get a
message after me i've never looked at
the message yet so i'm like who is this
and i'm like oh it's frothy
he's like hey good match bro i was like
that's what it was it was so cool it was
so cool yeah that was cool that was like
the first time i've like met someone i
knew through trials yeah that doesn't
happen for me often yeah it was cool
matchmaking was it
yeah another thing i'm really excited
about is i like that their new focus on
the campaign
yes how they wanted to be
um repeatable and like with like
different versions of
did they specifically say hard mode
legendary yeah legendary legendary some
type of hard mode legend mode yeah
yeah i mean
again halo i mean i'm used to that stuff
yeah and i'm excited to try that out
we need to put on the swords i mean
modifiers
yeah yeah yeah yeah
and
third thing
i mean the raid right yeah i love raids
so i would i would say pvp maps but
unfortunately that's not coming till
after yes yeah
let's not get ridiculous
yeah
that's not asking
you know what i'm waiting for that next
gambit map that's just that's top on my
list i've got to know when it drops
yeah especially since they sunsetted two
of them and one of them i really liked
that tangled shore one i know
you should never have gotten rid of any
of them
yeah yeah that's weird that's that's
still they are the dreaming city one i
thought that one looked pretty
it took forever to get to the certain
parts of the map needed to be reworked
yeah
what about yeah campaign
maybe you haven't thought of or thought
of recently which queen wants hope's
dreams desires fears
i still
i still want a second location that we
don't know about
that's that's the big dream the dreaming
city yeah that's like the big one it's
like
i know they said that they're never
going to be able to do like the size of
forsaken or whatever but my worry is
that
it won't have the end game legs that we
want it to have because
that for all of its
faults and it had quite a few beyond
light
it didn't really have much in the end
game like after you beat the raid there
were a few things there was like the
weekly events where we were figuring out
what was going on with um
what's-his-face robots
yeah that's it um and stuff like that
but there wasn't a ton i felt like we
were waiting pretty
pretty much right away whereas forsaken
there was like a month and a half almost
two months where every single week there
was some new stuff going on and i just
remember being like wow this game is
like huge and it felt more like an
annual expansion rather than just a
regular like seasonal thing so my thing
is i just want the end game to like be
there i want i want to i want which
queen to actually have legs i don't want
to be thinking about playing
um
you know what what game's next you know
after like two weeks with a witch queen
you know so even though there's going to
be like 50 other games coming out in
that one of course yeah
there's not enough time i mean yeah
there's not enough time in that month
yeah somebody said i need feb feb like
march timber i need to just make up a
month and squeeze one in there
yeah so i guess my answer is just
surprises i just want to be surprised by
anything during the uh during the dlc
for me i just want um
good transition to the raid i want good
narrative transition and i want um
i want true fear of sabbath theme i want
like real serious stakes
you know and i think i i think i agree
with you eve i don't know if you said it
or trav said it where it was kind of
like
you know i think it was you
i don't want a situation where we do it
we do the narrative and then we just go
in and we just squash her oh yeah not at
all if they do
kill her in a like a strike mission no
let's yeah savithine deserves so much
more and they got a voice actress for
her it's like it feels like they're
setting someone up who
if they do that too it seems like such a
waste like they're squandering such an
opportunity for
character arc and development
interesting story with crow and
everything we've got going on tomorrow
like if half of these people survive and
like no major people die which still
don't even know if that's going to
happen or if we'll get osiris like if
any and all these people keep going like
there's a whole lot of cool stuff that
can be told there and i just hope they
use this opportunity that they finally
have
set up some cards that kind of give you
a direction to go and go with them not
just no here you go and tip the house
over again absolutely and that's why
part of me feels like she she needs to
stay around a bit and and this thing has
to continue a little bit because
yeah like this all situation and the
squashing and you know are you still in
the camp of of us allying ourselves with
her in the end
i i i think so i i i just
i think they are the end of the campaign
or
i'm you know what it is it's the the
fact that the light somehow she's
manipulated and the light has quote
unquote
so that part of me
stills holding on to the hope that there
is not we're not done with her because
technically in a sense she's wonderful
we're also apparently hanging out in her
throne world and if she was dead that
would be a little weird if we're still
hanging out yeah
he's about to jump in yeah
yeah i think would you think that
sabbath
is going to be
i don't think we're going to be friends
i think she is going to be
the
her death is going to be what ends the
light in dark saga
so i don't think she's going around i
don't think she's leaving anytime soon
you know in uh avengers infinity war
where thanos wins let's go i think witch
queen is where savathun wins and we
spend the rest of the this saga
recovering from that and she's always
here
like that voice actors that they hired i
forget her name she's doing tons of
stuff
yeah extremely talented there's no way
that sabathan is just leaving if
anything she's either going to
be here until lightfall or i think my
theory is the end of this saga
interesting i would like that i think i
like that
out there
she plays such a
major role in now she's like us
supposedly she's going to be able to
wield the light and i'm assuming the
dark i'm assuming that like she already
can and does
so we're kind of on even playing fields
there's no way that she's just
knock on wood there's no way she just
leaves
and like we she dies like orcs and is
gone i i think she's staying for a while
i definitely think um there's a pretty
good chance she won't die and i i would
hope that that she doesn't because
that's been one of my criticisms forever
in destiny is that they don't keep their
villains around long enough but i agree
i would be so i feel like there would be
a lot of disappointment if she was the
ultimate evil for like the end of the
saga just because they've been building
up the darkness forever and if the
pyramid ships are just like not as
important as sabbathun and the grand
scheme of things i feel like people
would be like wait what was that i'm all
about like we were super afraid of the
pyramid chips this whole time and
sabbath yeah i mean see that's why i
worry about
the pyramidship
i was like that my worry about the
pyramid ships is
the closer and closer we get to the end
of the saga
you have to wonder how much again you
think of the resources it takes to
develop an entire race race yeah like
and to change game mechanics and model
like and different
so many more things that could come in
it's like they're flirting with maybe
another weapon type like the green you
know everybody jokes like it didn't make
it in this one maybe it'll make it a
lightfall for whatever reason they're
who knows how the retcon whatever they
were thinking about doing
but i was like if you got witch queen
there's two years left you put all the
effort into developing this like
brand new race that we haven't seen in
eight years
that's my only worry is that at this
point they're so far along and then
they've said this is the end of this
saga
to do something that big it does feel
like that's where you go posts light and
dark saga to me like if you do it for
two years it's like it's either a really
strong finish if they do but it's gonna
surprise me if they put that much effort
into something to finish the saga which
we do need a good finale to make it
matter but it is also a whole lot of
resources developed just brand new
enemies it's i mean i could see
different reskins like how we've seen
frozen and siva
that's where i could see them go but
like
um
yeah i just don't know if we're gonna
actually see like the veil like these
floaty ghostly race people it could
could be part of the reason that they
added another year to the saga because
the deflection running with lightfall
you know they got the final shape
yeah and also it seems to me like
they're building up a lot of mechanics
that are gonna
gonna go survive beyond the end of the
darkness and light saga because we
already know we can kind of infer based
on the way that they did uh
um the
i what's the ice how am i forgetting the
name of that
ice um element stasis
stasis jesus christ
like five months
anybody has ever listened if anybody has
ever listened to a podcast i just want
to stop this right there if you've ever
been listening to the podcast you're
working oh i totally know that word why
can't they think of it because it
literally happens to everybody at some
point you're in the middle of like i
can't think of the word what's the word
for the
the yeah exactly it happens especially
especially
especially if you're on a show and
there's like pressure to remember it
like immediately somebody will be like
somebody like hey what was that really
cool scout rifle on d1 and then my
brain's like hung jury hung jury but my
mouth's like
so uh yeah stasis we kind of know by the
way they set up stasis in the primary
slot that there's going to be two other
elements coming and they're going in the
primary slot too right like we've kind
of discussed that on the show that it
would it would just make sense if they
look like it would but at some point
then you'll have kinetic if there's two
more that go up there then you've got
four and then i don't know
i guess we'll see like i mean i
heavy will be everything and then the
primer will have three elements plus
kinetic and then the secondary slot will
also have three three separate elements
plus kinetic um but yeah that just looks
like managing like this has the square
root of
solar shields and arc divided by stasis
green i'm like what do i take into this
strike i don't know what to do anymore
they've got they've got that going for
them right and then they've got the fact
that we know that they're spending this
next year redoing all of the light uh
subclasses which that's also a lot of
work to do if you only have two more
years so i don't think i don't think
we're losing our light or darkness
powers no you know because that would
change the game completely you know so
if the light and dark can still exist
after the light and dark saga then so
could this new mob that they may be
unveiling you know what i mean so it's
true
in the same way that
the covenant are still around in halo
even though the war is over their
separate factions were fighting so
there's lots of i think workarounds
where you can kind of repurpose stuff i
mean we're still fighting the taken and
the taking king's been dead for a while
so
yeah that's still weird but yeah for
sure for sure yeah what else you got e
uh yeah well i mean that kind of covers
our guest a little bit if there's
anything else you guys wanted to ask or
we kind of feel like we tapped on most
things did we ask him any of the like
destiny questions like oh yes we know
how we got into destiny but we didn't
ask him like favorite raids or uh yeah
everything yeah good point drive good
point favorite top three raids
oh boy top three okay um
king's fall is number
one two one i'm gonna say one are you
sure i know it's controversial
i i change it all the time because
that and last wish like truly felt like
going into like the dungeon and
defeating the boss
those both had really strong elements of
that um
lat i mean last wish
riven
legit
is really tough and it's actually not
really my favorite encounter but the
rest of that raid where you're fighting
bosses and the sh
is it um
it's the second sure
that was a really unique way to defeat
them
yeah
yeah i thought that was really
interesting i think they they tried a
ton of different things with that raid
and they nailed like
a lot of aspects of that so
i don't know maybe i guess that's number
one i don't know like i said i don't
really know the switch
until you said this
during the podcast
good choices man good choice so yeah
the ranking
yeah uh king's fall was the first raid
that my team did like completely blind
so it kind of just holds a special place
in my heart
of course of course nothing nothing will
ever beat the moment where the taking
king shows up in my opinion yeah
it's a hard one
even when you're fighting an amkara it
like it really is nothing you're just
you kind of don't even really really
understand what you're looking at but
when you saw
orcs come out you were like this is
insane like
that that moment yeah so really quick
story by the one guy on my team he's a
really quiet reserved dude right he's
very calm i think i see where this
i know this is going we're all in our
inventory and he's a hunter he's just
like all right let's go let's go let's
go like that's kind of like but he's
quiet about it you know he's
he's letting us do his thing and he goes
all of a sudden we hear
um guys and we're like what the music
starts playing he goes
uh that guy that we're fighting he's uh
he's really big and then we we got rid
of like the screen like of our character
and i see this giant
high
and that moment lives in my head forever
because the guy that was quiet reserved
just uh guys guys
that dude we're fighting he's really
like right now
he uh
he took the swole pills and
we have to deal with exactly
i think one thing ever
no mine was just
i think his scale worked even better
because he's on this like this outer
kind of little platform on the ship and
you have the planet in the background
i swear it almost gives him more scale
so like that's yeah it was the eclipse
that's perfect combination yeah yeah
yeah i i also went blind into that raid
and i feel like everyone who went blind
into
that raid and got that moment they got
the ultimate reward for not looking
things up online because i'm a big
advocate for like never looking anything
up online for a video game i just like
to figure things out even if it takes me
a longer time um but that moment dude
like one guy took off his helmet you
know his headset and you could hear him
like going berserk in the background it
sounds like he was like running up and
down his hallway going like
i know that's like i mean there were the
memes yeah there were the memes people
like holy like people were just losing
their mind that is one of those that i
remember and
i was thinking about sekiro because i
cannot remember why it came up could
have been the last hand thing but there
is a
one of the bosses you fight in sakura
had literally a viral set of reactions
that went out kind of similar the way to
the first time you saw oryx
the first time this happened which one
is it
it's the ape
oh part two yeah yeah that's that's yeah
yeah so it's like you'll see i was
trying not to say anything but yeah it's
probably been a couple years ago yeah
you're good
but yeah like those moments like there
are a few moments that you see like
travel the internet in reactions and
oryx is one of them that's what i was
like i yeah i i would really like to see
one of those again like the scale the
grandiose nature of
you know a god in his shadow realm
planet size you're like oh okay i'm tiny
even like this his hand smashing you're
like
yeah i'm i'm so like holy crap yeah it's
epic you know um shout out to
brian mancus who we've had on you know
the artist and he's got a tremendous oh
i love that one yeah artists of of of
king's fall with the scale of oryx and
then the platform
it's just like the small guard how am i
new they are
in scale to oryx and yeah like that
moment you can never i still remember
the music
i remember everything about it the
blights the different strategies the
teleportation into the little world
where you got to fight your way out and
um yeah that was a moment man when you
beat him especially hard mode you beat
him on hard mode that was a thing that
was a thing it was just a great raid
it's just you know so many different
encounters golgoroth the sisters you
know so many things the the the phallic
wall that i had
yeah
ah
different things there
the only thing i hate because i would
tear off a wall like i'm a terrible
jumper
it wasn't working on you that's just
platforming
yeah but let me finish your story before
you blow me it so the whole thing is
when you get to the part with the ships
and there's this one jump where you kind
of gotta let go
i would be the bane of every fire team
like everybody's like car game ready
yeah come on guys like they all partying
on the other side they molding making
fun of me and i'm like
i can't
like i was terrible at that but i used
to literally have panic attacks that's
like what are we getting there just pull
me forward
i'll quit i'll join back just take me
where i gotta go i hate it that far but
other than that
excellent raid excellent excellent oh so
so that's why that's not ranked aside
just the emotional scarring that it has
on news no it's like right it's just
it's a great rate i still i still think
the war priest is the best encounter in
that race i like wool priests
it's
it's simple and pure and the boss is
awesome just so cool yes yes yep great
great rate great rate can't say too many
bad things about that rate and i never
said uh my third but i'm gonna cheat
here a little bit let's go because it's
not a raid but it holds a special place
is skolas
ah
there we go oh
that was a really i wasn't or ever go
laughs no house
first week or first week when it was
impossible or second week when you nuked
his butt
was first week solar burn i think so or
was that arc burn i think first was
solar i guess you could nuke him that
week with like gal horn if you had it
right gala horn yeah and then people
because this is like before they nerfed
him he had a nerf
uh because then people tried fourth
horsemen and then there was controversy
because fourth person was only on
playstation at the time yeah so
that was a big debate i remember but
that um
the whole like poison elements you have
to like trade between your teammates i
thought that was cool it's a great
mechanic you're right i forgot about
that yeah i really like that fight
i really enjoyed that fight
it's one of those moments where they're
pushing you up to the edge of what's
manageable but
kind of did
speaking of what's manageable anybody go
uh flawless freelance this weekend
did anybody play trials did anybody go
freelance freelance how really how was
everybody just experienced
yeah how was i let's start with travis i
got to hear about this
yeah uh the matchmaking was bad um it
was just you know like like basically it
takes out all the stuff out of trials
that like you know you
you like about trials like the teamwork
and coordination and trials kind of
requires coordination because you only
get one life and you're down and so
if you're if if all teams are just like
not talking at all and just random h it
sort of is just chaos and so i played it
i was like i'm glad that it's so easy to
get into trials that part's good but the
experience is really not like
does not resemble anything close to like
a good trials experience just in my my
limited experience i won some matches i
lost some matches then i was like all
right i i at least got a taste for this
you know but yeah my i did not go
flawless and my overall i i didn't even
really play long enough to go flawless i
was just kind of trying it out just so i
could have something to say on the show
but uh it yeah my experience with it was
that it was like you know it's like any
other match made like comp playlist it's
sort of
you gotta make the most out of it what
you can but you definitely feel it with
the um no red only one life thing like
you feel the matchmaking kind of
thing and you can actually see it in
bungie's data they put a bunch of data
on that and you saw that the five zero
matches like the really lopsided matches
were higher on the freelance uh playlist
and that definitely like shows like
they're they're it's it's hard to match
make a
completely random team so
proteon your experience
uh zero experience i was not able to
participate in this week oh okay gotcha
what was smart from what um
trav is saying i i've heard similar
things so
yeah
e
i was gonna say cog did you get a chance
to play
i was gonna save you you always put me
up next um no you go you go i'm curious
i'm very curious about your experience
uh i played a decent amount this weekend
i'm trying to see if i can kind of get a
check on how many matches i played i
tend to play a lot of solo that's just
generally what happens is
kind of how that falls so whether it's
like friday saturday i was looking up
sunday
didn't do much because i had some stuff
but tuesday i ended up getting my seven
wins i'm gonna play it enough to get to
that i mean as travis said it's like
yeah you're not having that much
communication so you are kind of
seeing what people do trying to react to
that see if people are going to play
smart i think i was listening to
what was i listening to
could remember if it was fallout or
firing range and they're just like all
the titans just like run straight in oh
oh
no the water's back
oh he's back
you're good you're exactly good he's
good you're good you're good i'm good
but yeah the connection the stream will
be strange you said yeah yeah stream
will come back um hopefully
it's all good but yeah so let's listen
to fire ding range and they're just like
oh it's like you know somebody just like
there's always the one person that just
like bee-lined straight into the other
person's door like what are you doing
over there like
just hang out for a second just a second
see what happens
there's always those and even me like
not high skilled learn a lot from pretty
much anybody that i probably play with
who's better than me which is a lot of
people but even i can give of some basic
people some pointers of like
here's the map
you should probably not go straight into
there if you get to a door and you see
big red things on your radar first look
at your radar like just some basic stuff
that you notice that i'm like i'm kind
of being more aware i'm trying to stick
more to the 60 40 i'm actually trying to
think about that a little bit more
i mean i'm trying to be conscious
i will i will take the so-called un
unskilled player who's like more aware
and team oriented over the hot head try
hard
because that guy ruins the team and like
yeah there's no vetting process and yeah
like when i go into trials and we like
it's like what just me and my buddy we
have a random third yeah i i'd prefer if
that random third were to just like hang
out with us and stay with the team
rather than run right by himself yeah i
got strats i it's funny i'll wait to eat
fish i'll tell you my experience with
east video i know but i mean as you guys
are saying it's like that person at
least could maybe hang back and res
couple things please rest people
yes that's a thing please
use your super
yes why do people be holding on thank
you oh my because sometimes i'm like all
right we got one that's gonna change it
and then you're like oh you still that
you don't feel it's time it was like
like a youtube video for you
five things not to do in trials like as
a solo player
yeah like just knowing that i mean
this is like pvp like creators are
probably so much better at this but even
for me
i tweeted out even i was just all the
tweet was was user super and follow was
like he's saving it for next game i'm
like damn it
i was like it was perfect but i was like
that's what you feel like i'm like they
have four it's match point like an
attendant like this is it this is the
time to click the button
yeah
uh so you'll have some frustrating
moments and then there's some times
where you'll be like
there are times where i'm like i i
paired up with a god like i'm in here
just being like tell you why you're
gonna like jump in a backpack here and
be like this guy you that's the person
when you see him like hey this guy's
going in for the flank in the door and
all of a sudden they've got two kills
like every round i'm like i don't even i
just have to keep an eye on the other
guy i just at that point all i do is
watch bodies if you pair with a god
watch bodies like be defensive like kind
of watch your radar just stick that's
another thing for like a basic thing if
someone dies on the other team
don't leave the body if you're not
entirely sure what to do at least stay
with the butt like these are basic
things like that you want to scream
through your computer
and it's like and i get this is where
this is travis frustration i 100
get that this is the frustration but on
the other side i will tell you
saint needs to be everywhere in this
damn game
yeah he's so funny i
i could be having the worst match and
he's like
this is match point you've been down too
far before it's like everything he says
make all makes all of my matches
oh it's so good like it would be great
if
like the example that you were saying
like someone goes too far from your body
and he's like guardian what are you
doing go back to your teammates oh yeah
just a couple instructions from st would
be really nice you use your super
guardian
you showed me the light bro
i but i mean i will say for me it's like
i had my ups and i had my downs
but i will tell you every time i started
another match i knew
i did not have to check the roster to
see if i was against the three stack
yeah
and for me it's like some are gonna be
good some are gonna be trash and i
totally get that but i can tell you
every time i start i'm like
at least i know
they're all everybody's in that same
same situation there's gonna be god's on
one side there's gonna be gods on my
team i'm gonna watch somebody get
backpacked on the other side i'm gonna
be in somebody else's every so often i'm
gonna be on top of the leaderboard which
i'm like i don't even know how that
happens
but like there's enough randomness to it
that it isn't just like punishing to me
right so that's why for me i
i found it more manageable because i
wasn't checking the roster every time
it's like i'd see the loadouts and play
sure i wasn't going in and like three
and like just defeated at the start of
the night you see it when you see that
the two people on the other side of the
clan logo with the same three in the
clan
is not gonna go good bro yeah i mean if
you finish i'll just
go for it that's that's kind of mine
it's like i even though they're like the
win and loss ratio may not be that great
for me overall it's still something
i hope they bring back at least every so
often as we've kind of mentioned and
we'll kind of get to that but it's like
it's one of those for me that
there was as a solo player it's kind of
the nice way
right because i feel everybody's
experience is different you know i agree
with travis in a sense that like
it is it is definitely wild west they
i'm not even going to sugarcoat it it is
very much the wild west like you don't
know what you're going to get you don't
know how it's going to go down you know
i usually jump into it with what i'm
like
what the first two rounds is my
assessment period
that's when i was like okay
who what's his name okay what is he
doing right and i look at who's dying
first like who's getting picked first
right so if we if we don't like we lose
the first round the first two i'm
following that guy i want to know what
you're doing right so that's so that's
me being a lot of times when i adopt
that strategy it kind of helps the team
because some people are being over
aggressive they're not doing what
they're supposed to but then i've had
experiences
in
when i was doing freelance when it was
the other way without i mean without
free landscaping was just regular
matchmaking
but i was noticing it too many times i'm
the best player with the blueberries and
i'm i'm okay but i ain't that great to
be carrying two blueberries with this
every couple of matches eat and i ain't
going for this the part that felt good
i gotta shout this man now shout out to
orrick orrick's son there was i was like
yo you the the match start and it was
like two bodies down already i'm like oh
he's a beast i'm going where he going so
it became this thing where i get excited
when there's actually a very good play
it was so rare i felt it happened the
other way in freelance right but this
way i was just like yo every once in a
while i had like a god on my team and i
was learning and to the point where he
did some plays
where it was like
last guardian standing with him won
three in dudes so
match and i don't get me wrong like he
had like 16 kills i better have eight
the guy who was playing was very bad
like that the third guy blueberry was
awful
he texted me after the mess he's like yo
my back is hurting for all the carrying
i'm doing like he's he's cursing that
like the third dude yeah and i'm like
bro i you should be cursing at me
because you you carried me too he's like
nah dude you were good you were good and
then we ended up being friends and then
we linked up and let's play some regular
joints and i've had a couple of
experiences like that that i know would
have not happened any other way outside
this environment i still agree with
travis in the sense that
they still need this is the problem now
we're not having skill based or any type
of the ranking system because now
when everyone's willy dilly
it's it's the super wild west right you
you anything can happen so you get all
this varying skill level stuff but shout
out to the people i was shocked i didn't
i was shocked that
how many people that i knew
went flawless that way
that surprised me like i shout out to
the ashton luca
shout out to i think liz i think he's in
here a couple of people in my clan went
flawless this way and i thought it's
just like so much luck of the draw i
thought i would never encounter that but
people were encountering it so it's
interesting we'll get into the data and
stuff like that it listen it still needs
work i ain't gonna say it sugarcoat it
like yes it's there and all that but i
was surprised with certain aspects that
were fun and certain aspects that i'm
like okay this this needs work and i
didn't get a chance to play i'm very
curious if any of you
proteon trav any of you guys during the
freelance weekend
i'm apparently didn't play this week but
um
anybody played regular
or matchmaking without the freelance i'm
curious if the competitive aspect
went up or was it changes for those
people who played exclusively that way
yeah
i should preface this by saying i didn't
um i didn't play it this that way this
weekend i just didn't know i didn't have
to do it freelance
i did freelance just because i wanted to
try it while it was there yeah of course
and it was easy to jump into right um
but uh
i think two two things one
i think i think the wild west nature of
the freelance playlist speaks even more
to my desire for there to be like some
sort of ranking system right just a
seasonal ranking system needs to be
a way to group these things
uh that said i'm glad that freelance
exists because i don't think that three
v three stacks should be preying on on
solo queuers and the thing that said i
think in order for this to work if
they're gonna have a freelance playlist
permanently or even on a trial basis in
the future they need to not let players
join the
3v playlist because i was going to ask
you that
the icon for freelance is small
and people don't see it or they don't
know that it's a thing and they join the
regular trials playlist and it messes up
the experience for people who want to
play three views so i think either just
don't let them do it so
pretty much three stacks only on that
one nope you do not have enough members
in your fire team to play this mode go
play the freelance version or it needs
to give
and this would not be my preference just
because i don't think they should even
have the opportunity but
uh if they if they do insist on playing
that mode or they click on it there
should just be like an alert like hey
you're alone in your fire team
would you like to play this other mode
yeah literally like did you mean did you
mean to click on this other button
because obviously those are going to be
a good experience the in-game
like instruction guidance for a lot of
things in this game
is lacking
like i mean somebody there's i don't
think there's an instruction in how to
play gambit for a new player is there
i mean they can click on the node thanks
so much when i first came out there was
like those instruction tool tips at the
bottom but i think that only appears
your first game
yeah
i was like so he's like oh yeah it's not
duncan that's it wow yeah so it's like a
brand new person's like van gaal what's
gambit oh let me click on that what do i
do like yeah there's no tool tips
there's no tutorial video there's
that that stuff always and again same
thing with trials it's like
you were a solo player it's like are you
sure you want to do this and you could
click even something like you know click
l trigger if you never want to see this
warning again but you know you're by
yourself would you like to try the
freelance playlist and you could clear
it once a weekend or something like that
when it's up
just to make people aware of it as
travis said because the solo should not
be going in there and really like for
travis like three stacks or solos
it is weird for twos at that point but
then that gets at least back to
if two's in there one random person is
kind of getting screwed exactly it can't
it can't be twos because then they're
you have to allow ones if you allow two
so there's like a weird uh
area
and you can't you can't also allow the
twos in the freelance playlist because
then it it kind of takes a job of the
people who are solo queuing so there's
not really good solution again this is
one of the things i was like i'm worried
about matchmaking and trials because it
just there's a lot of issues with it i
want to read this uh tweet that trials
report put out because i think it's
hilarious i i retweeted it some of you
guys may have seen it it says there was
a guardian that played trials for the
very first time this weekend
they solo queued for 184 matches all in
the regular playlist
29 wins 174 kills
1039 deaths
amount of matches in freelance zero
hmm
so
that is a guy who just played 184 trials
matches this weekend none in the
freelance playlist because presumably
because they did not know it was a thing
and we had a had a pretty terrible
experience 29 wins out of 184 matches so
i i again like there needs to be at
least a way to let these people know
that the freelance exists and direct
them in that way because 184 matches and
i mean that's
yeah that's bad that's very unfortunate
i feel bad yeah i mean i know some
people who
i mean i'm one of them like i
the only times i've done trials actually
this entire season has just been with me
and my one friend and we're just
randomly searching for a third you put a
weird spot into these
fire teams that too um
like
and plus you know if this if this
freelance option does become like a
better like ver an easier way to go
flawless then some teams might purposely
just not play with one another because
the threes is just gonna be sweatier
than the individuals yeah that's why i
was gonna ask you guys a question when
you finish
yeah so you create like this weird
scenario where the threes playlist is
harder and harder to go flawless than
the freelance version
if if freelance continues to be easier
to go like more people are going
flawless than that regularly it's just
it's a weird scenario
yeah i'm curious i know we're going to
get into the the details of the um the
statistics that they're going to break
up with the uh and bungie in the twap i
guess my question for you guys because i
do agree with the aspect of
the twos and you know one guy going in
there and the two is going in that kind
of you know the uneven the random nature
of it you know what i'm very curious if
like what would you guys say if they
came to this i'm just hypothetically
okay with conclusion they're like okay
freelance is here to stay right
but then they go
you have to match make
with like old trials so what if they
came up with that's their data solution
how would you guys feel about it what
freelance cards only or so freelance
freelance how it is as it as it is now
right yeah
and then they bring back old school
trials without matchmaking for the
threes
how would you feel about that
i think that's fine i i think you almost
have to do that if you want true
separation otherwise you're always gonna
have the people that just don't know
about the freelance playlist or whatever
and and that's even worse experience
because if you don't know about the
freelance playlist you're probably not a
hardcore destiny player you're probably
not going to perform especially well so
it's like an even worse kind of like
sign like when i find a solo queuer
playing in the comp playlist
not in freelance like if i'm playing
with one other guy and then we get a
solo queue i'm like wow this guy's going
to be really really bad because he
doesn't know about the freelancers
and i'm always right i'm always like
right on the money like if you find
somebody there they are really bad
because they didn't know about freelance
um
so yeah i think that's a problem but to
uh prothean's point if you create a high
barrier of entry and a low barrier of
entry and the lowberry of entry has more
casual players who don't have teammates
that could become an easier bet for the
ultra sweaties without any sort of
ranking system then you just pray on
solo queues and go to the freelance
playlist and it effectively kills the
original trials mode either way so again
this is like one of the problems i had
at the beginning when they were doing
this is like all right well if they
separate it then that means all the
casuals are in freelance and it just
adds so many like questions of like is
trials
is the old version of trials or a
competitive version of trials even going
to be practical once you put matchmaking
in the mix and i think it gets more
complicated the more you try to like
break it up and so freelance was a
interesting experiment but i'm
interested to see what kind of data they
took from that or learnings because my
perception is that
it creates even more
complexities and potential uh pitfalls
so
the audio is going to say something or
i'm sorry
oh you're good okay
okay i thought probably i had something
no it's interesting i'm very curious
wanted to ask you guys that question and
um i know we're going to you want to
transition into the thing um the top
yeah that's about the cops
yeah um so for the twab
this would get bungee uh they touched on
you know last week of festival lost
knock your stuff out most of this is
about trials so first they said trials
match making changes a quick recap of
the stats from the last few weeks
matchmaking times are consistent with
past few weeks blowout rates dropped
slightly week over week this is
consistent with lower skilled players
not playing as much average hours played
per player remains consistent across
skill levels
overall player counts went down each
week but that is expected during this
portion of the season and that is
consistent with past trials and iron
banner performance
we still don't see any evidence of
widespread flawless card resets to avoid
the flawless pool
less than point five percent of cards
played were reset while flawless and
still above three wins
even
excuse me even still the impetus to do
this should be removed starting this
week more on that below
so that's basically just the idea about
those stats do those
does i do those all sound positive to
you guys like things are going in a good
direction is there any weird outlier you
guys hear of there anything before i
talk about freelance
casual players doesn't sound good
that's naturally going to happen though
as any casual player is going to fall
off like they do expect that to a point
you can't keep everybody playing this
game for the entire time but it does
sound like it is not not good though no
i mean that's definitely one and that's
why i think even the numbers this
weekend actually seem pretty good i'm
i'm more so curious if they have the
data on
if there's players playing destiny just
not trials
are the people who were playing trials
those first few weeks are they playing
this weekend
good point i feel like that's a better
measurement rather than just overall
population of trying yes because that's
a good metric
coming out of this season
sure and a long season yeah
i feel like that'd be an easier way to
point to like are those casual players
not playing because of the experience
are they not playing because they just
have the loot that they wanted i know a
lot of people said they're just gonna
play trials they get the loot and
they're done that's what i was saying
that's my point that's my point and and
the fact that again
it's a long season you know at the end
of the day the reward there was one
really new reward right reed's regret
after you get your reads you get your
vorpal you get your triple tap
everything else is pretty much a reissue
of stuff we've been already had you know
kind of thing and and i think it's just
a combination of those two things that's
what i was curious about but i think
you're right project with that i'm very
curious about that stat you know if that
data was released what what what do we
get from that very interesting yeah
yeah so this past weekend they open up
the freelance queue so that solo players
could consistently play against each
other said they had over a million games
played in each playlist both freelance
and standard everybody
with slightly more games played in the
base trials playlist so even though the
freelance had
like a good number of games it also
sounds like the base playlist had still
a little bit more games played in
matches played average hours played for
lower skilled players is up quite a bit
over the past weeks that's actually a
good thing for
lower skilled kind of lower barrier to
entry well the average to top end has
almost the same hours played
so that's kind of weird to say lower
skilled players hours are up
average players are about the same
and yet they did say the overall player
counts were down each week so it's like
skill level
seems to be in a reasonable place
because if you say more casual players
are actually playing i think that's
probably a good thing if the average is
still the same
uh interestingly players who played in a
fire team some of the time and solo some
of the time played almost three times as
long this weekend as players who either
played exclusive either way
uh they said player numbers 244 000
freelance exclusive 120 000 fire team
exclusive 220 000 played both and the
25.5 percent of players went flawless
lower than any revamp week
so before we get into like blowout rates
and anything like that i said average
matchmaking times were consistently
around 50 seconds for full fire teams
and solos uh and regularly we're about
100 seconds for duos obviously it makes
sense you guys kind of
explained why
sunday flawless pool adds about 10
seconds to the flawless player
matchmaking we are seeing some wearing
spikes in matchmaking during times of
the smaller subpools post flawless spool
split um so yeah before i talk about
blowouts
anything from you guys there that you
can interpret from those numbers like
decent populations flawless percent
anything dots
gents
[Music]
i feel like they didn't give us the full
they didn't give us enough information
for us to draw a new like super
meaningful conclusions at least that's
kind of like that's how i'm feeling yeah
yeah yeah i mean the first week
like they said average trials games per
player like there's a chart
uh the first week it looks like average
trials games per trials player week one
was like 37 38
week two dropped to about 28. week three
was about the same week four was about
the same week five was a little less
probably like 24 23 and then week six
actually bumped up a little bit to about
26. so i'd actually see a bump up in
trial average games because of freelance
right yeah so it's like more games but
the one i thought was interesting is
they said the people who played a mix of
both both yeah that was interesting they
played three times as long and honestly
i think that's kind of a way for
take somebody like travis to see if he's
willing well normally he'll play with
his fire team when they're on and around
and that's when he's gonna play because
you know schedules and everything but
then now if every soft and he's just
like i got a little bit time before
breakfast or before i go to bed let me
pop in for a couple solo matches you
actually get the option to
jump in both playlists that way and it
gives you a little more flexibility to
go hardcore with the threes and then
like i don't have anybody on right now
but i want to get a couple in let's see
what happens in solo just for
entertainment like
i think that actually did work to some
benefit to truly have that solo option i
wonder why that that specifically
was like such a big standout versus when
you know freelance wasn't there when you
could just you could queue in either way
as a solo but is it like were you more
curious was it people wanted to check
out the playlist what do you guys think
yeah that was strange to me that that
one i was surprised by because i'm like
i'm trying to understand the mindset
whereas
i was thinking that when the solo queue
launched
you know that obviously you're going to
get an influx of players playing it and
i get that but
for people to go solo they say i still
want to do the fire team as well it's
interesting i i don't know what to make
of that it was just very strange to me i
was just i didn't expect that what you
thinking
i think for players that
know trials which are probably the
people that are doing this since they're
playing so much right
it's like if you if you were playing in
that first week and you had a fire team
and you were you were the on the side of
i'm gonna play only with the fire team
and stomp people that aren't in the fire
team then if your fire team's not there
you basically just don't play or you
right you go into comp freelance because
you're not gonna go in and just like
willingly get stomped but if there's
this other playlist that's freelance
only and your team's not around then i
would be willing to hop in because at
least i know it's an equal playing field
it's not as bad of a
that's probably what it is i think
that's definitely what it is i think i
didn't think about that until you said
that yeah
i agree
no i was gonna say that just sounds like
it has some
some benefits of the freelance being
there giving you the option to know that
like
not gonna get totally stomped at least
there's some time like for a random
one-off
um the next thing they talk about is
blowouts so when they're talking about
five o's five ones
um
was almost as low as our best
post-pre-vamp week when flawless pool
went active friday at like 27
uh this was powered by significant
number of fire teams versus fire team
matches and solos for solos both of
which had 25 blowout rate so they go
through a bunch of stats of like
what matches fall into five oh five one
five two five three five four
and the main thing they state somewhere
later on i'll probably get to it they're
trying to get 20 20 they're trying to
get it to be 20 on all those
they're trying to get it toward the
skill somehow or
don't say skill because that'll piss
everybody off but they're trying to get
to where we'll get to that discussion
here in a little bit because i've been
like watching some tweets that are
interesting
um
5.0 games in the freelance playlist are
25 for 5.0
five one is twenty six point one
five two
twenty point four
five three fifteen point six five four
twelve point four
the regular playlist five oh games
thirty percent
five one twenty five five two eighteen
five three thirteen five four eleven
it's like a bigger range but it falls
like faster down it's weird
yeah uh they said one thing they aren't
happy with is the team balancing we've
noticed uh that how
the solo playlist isn't doing a great
job balancing teams when they aren't
when there aren't any fire team
mismatches for trials it's currently
just picking teams randomly
shocking because we all literally just
described it could be who knows how it
feels
uh we are going to be looking carefully
at um how teams are selected over the
next few weeks and hopefully have a
better bounce
uh the next time freelance rolls around
uh this was one of the downsides of not
using skill based matchmaking and trials
situations where skill would be helpful
to balance two teams of solo players
it isn't even a data point the system
can look at speaking of which
talk about freelance futures uh
we like the overall outcome and the vibe
of the freelance queue and both
playlists seems to have a kind of
variable a viable amount of players we
are looking at running freelance
occasionally for the remainder of season
15. thumbs up for me there that it's
every so often but are still trying to
determine what feels right we'll let you
know long term we're exploring some
single playlist solutions preferable
preferential matchmaking of full fire
teams against full fire teams duo plus
one duo plus one and then solos they
don't have a specific release target for
that
uh but it will not be prior to season
16. and i guess i gotta ask my question
why is that not now
if they're if freelance is not going to
be around now
why
is that matchmaking not already a
priority like fire team should be
playing fire teams
every time in my opinion if the option
is there if it's one playlist if it's
one pool team team two and one two and
one full solos
because the advantages
swing really fast and solos even if
you're like all solos
yo that look wow funny
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
my rsp is just giving me so many memes
tonight
of those classics that was classic
anyway whenever this stream is awful and
i'm so sorry to everybody but with the
uploads and the audio for you guys will
get the good ones with the jokes in
between
yes yes um
what was i saying
you're talking about why
oh yeah so like if you're
so if you're a team of three solos
and then you pair against even a pair if
they're in the same clan and they know
each other that's already a disadvantage
because two out of three
at least can play together and then you
have the unknown like idiot who runs in
or the person who hangs back but still
that advantage gets big and then the two
versus three is again another big leap
in advantage
i guess i wanted to ask you guys
why not do that now why do you think
they're not doing it now because to me
it seems like an obvious thing to do
i know there's not skill based but i
mean
that does seem to be
pew pew fingers indeed apparently
that's why that's why they're not doing
it now to punish the bonuses of the
world
yeah that stupid cheetah guy that we
keep hearing about every so often
he tweeted at dmg and caused it to fire
on twitter yeah let's piss on his first
button he bought him bad damn
there we go
there we go mine's probably off there we
go all right he's back what up
this is the only thing i could think of
is like matchmaking times
i mean other than that i don't know why
they wouldn't just do fire team fire
team soul over solo
yeah matchmaking times technical
limitations since it's not an eververse
uh who knows
factor
yeah well it's not never verse so it can
it can have technical limitations all
the silver that's being uh bought for
the dino armor is going towards the
trials matchmaking
that's what they're going to use that
money for okay
so let me ask you guys this they say
and again stream is who knows what's
gonna happen so hopefully you guys enjoy
this one later on
somebody's driving by outside damn yeah
it wasn't me this time no that was
travis he had like a truck outside
motorcycle
motorcycle
he's actually in the back of a trailer
right now
[Laughter]
okay so 50 seconds seems to be like
their matchmaking number they have and i
guess they're trying to keep it under a
minute if possible but it's like
i don't know what matchmaking is like
for say for other things where you going
to battle royals and you take a while to
build up the 100 then you got the
loadings that like that stuff takes
minutes to get into i'm like would you
wait 30 40 more seconds for quality
matches if it just takes a little while
to get there
i mean it's a tough spy i mean
i personally would right but
they're in this tough spot because
there was such pushback against
skill-based matchmaking
because of connection
and
the problem i see that they're having
is that
trials theoretically should be skill
based hacking theoretically it should
have
people of equal skill facing each other
so
you know i'm very curious
and again i technical limitations and
the jokes we have but it's like i'm very
curious with you know the lack of
dedicated servers and things of that
nature that things that you know other
other games should have but
they're in a tough spot because it to me
this scree i look at this it screams
skill based to me it screams it's like
you need to get that in this mode right
thus you're not gonna you're gonna keep
playing with the data you're gonna keep
having these random things and i think
that this is the issue right now the
issue is two twofold that's how i look
at them
one was they came into it
we cannot do this mold without the
cheating right
box checked anti-cheat for the most part
like i don't hear about it right i don't
care about the craziness right it seems
tempting and the second part they had
pillar they had was okay
population is dead right we got to get
on board and we got to get the ease of
entry the accessibility and all this
stuff and stuff right so now we're kind
of there these two pillars seem at least
solid from from the data they have right
but the third pillar now is what we've
been preaching which is skill which is
matching people fairly and doing the
right thing and i think
i don't know if it's a technical
limitation
or
why because the only thing i can think
of is i remember the dedicated servers
right we know it's dedicated services
i'm trying to be nice i'm trying to be
nice right but i remember the days when
they tried skill base
and the pvp community was like nah bro
that was different though
that so that was that was a true skill
based system but it was a completely
a black box solution that seemed to be
based off of play time and
was not not the same what they really
need is a seasonal rank-based system of
course you do not need skill-based
matchmaking they need ranks like in
rocket league because right then you
yeah and i just think that they couldn't
probably sustain that type of model if
they implemented in trials
before because the population was so low
but right now they might be able to do
it right and that's my question i would
that's my question
i would i would love to see uh like a
ranked system kind of like how apex does
it i think apex system is really really
nice yes
like the competitive mode the
competitive playlist needs that really
badly and
even if not that just the trials
playlist or like just like you just
we just need something i mean i agree i
feel like they've been struggling with
like how they want to
do matchmaking and destiny ever since
it's launched forever there's still
games
of
regular cruise while play where like the
team balance is like the lobby balance
is like terrible nightmare yeah iron
banner is a nightmare all the time i i i
generally don't have fun in iron banner
anymore sometimes because a lobby
balance
blowouts don't they like iron banner
feels like even in freelancers yeah yeah
i'm the type of guy who thinks that
there should be a competitive rank and a
social rank
you should have to take it back to old
school halo yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly
should apply to trials you should apply
to comp maybe iron banner and then the
social playlist will apply to every
other competitive playlist and you just
increase your rank over time
and uh you know i i think that that
would serve them better because again
it doesn't it's not even about the game
mode it's about the experience of
playing with people that are way above
your level or way below you there's some
people who really like just like pub
stomping which i i do not understand why
people enjoy that but
i i think we can all agree that at least
50 percent of the people in a lopsided
match are not having a good time
probably more i also don't really get
particularly uh happy when i'm just
destroying a team that's way below my
skill level so i just think uh it could
benefit everyone if they implemented
something like that so that's kind of
like good reference old school halo 2.
yeah for sure
and that's one of those i wonder is like
so when you say connection
that i get when it comes to skill
because if you're in a higher skill
level and the higher and higher you get
then potentially you're playing people
that are worse and worse connection
because it's having to search farther
and farther
i get that to a point and that's again
where when we talk about a playlist
people are worried about dividing up the
pool well is there going to be pushback
if you divide up the pool into these
like
bronze silver gold platinum diamond
ranks and you're like okay well here's
this my population somewhere around here
but half of this population's
all over the world yeah matchmaking is
going to be longer that that's just
going to have to cut i mean that's just
the nature of it right sorry to
interrupt but i think that that see the
problem they're having it's
philosophically they i get the
impression that they like the idea of
quickly matching
they like that it seems that like they
mentioned it multiple times
every week they like yo
the times and my thing is i'm with
travis on which like i'm willing to wait
for a more balanced match in any time a
lot of people aren't i think a lot of
people that's probably what it is i
think gamers have very short attention
span and they've seen metrics that just
drop off when people have long
matchmaking wait times yeah because i
guess it's something that they're a lot
more worried than
i'm guilty of it because i remember the
halos you know systems and it's just
like i'm cool you know i'm cool we're
waiting whatever because again it's
going to be
more to to someone of my skill level and
i that seems to be the data they are
hanging on to
and that's the question if if they're
going to put the resource or whatever
technical issue that they need to do
to to implement the skill or the ranking
so that
you know it can it can have the type of
matches that we're talking about for
these type of modes but i'm sorry i
totally cut you off i suppose i know
you're about to say something
no i mean that does pretty much cover it
it's because
yeah i was like i'm trying to figure out
where all this is going to land and you
guys are talking about you know time
comes up multiple times i'm like
i know like there's something's like
i'll wait for a strike i'll go grab a
cup of water and come back and there's
other times it goes pretty quick it's
like you never sometimes that stuff just
takes a little longer but it's like
right
again the issue
i would say probably the high end of
people would worry about would be
connection and when you bring that up
that's probably one of the only pieces
when it comes to the high skill system
that it worries about that i would say
a high skill player would have a
legitimate concern about because if you
are playing with lag central like that
sucks
it does like that actually
yeah that i get but as you said on the
other side
somebody tweeted out and like i replied
it was like legitimate question
like when should i as like an average at
best player play against
an upper echelon player
and this is the question for anybody
when do you guys think until you quit
[Laughter]
like okay legitimately though like
prothean do you think i should ever face
that person in my current skill in any
game mode
ideally
no
but
if you look like realistically it's it's
gonna happen
and that's how i feel about it i don't
have much more to say like it's it's
just that's how things are twenty
percent of the time apparently according
to the stats
oh really well when you have twenty
percent of the times they're shut out oh
true okay
yeah
yeah i don't know i i don't feel that
way i'm actually surprised that they
said that they want twenty percent on
each of those um yeah they said zero
they're not in the blowout they want
twenty percent off
right
yeah
didn't they say in the post that they
they were shooting for zero percent on
the blowout yeah i'm trying to i'm not
in this room in an ideal wheeled world
we want to get each one of those numbers
to as close to 20 as possible but we
would rather see more five to four
outcomes than five to one so they'd like
to see an average of twenties like for a
pretty even split but even tipping more
towards five to four and five to three
right now it's tipping five to zero five
to one so they want to shift those
numbers
to the other side of where they are
right now that's their
game goal
i think they want there to be like zero
five to zeros which makes sense like
it's just not fun if you're winning zero
rounds
yeah
yeah um
i lost my chain of thought
no you're good you're good
i was gonna say it was like cog do you
think i should ever face like oh i'm
sorry i don't know like do you think i
should be facing the mercury's is the
kami's the drewskis do you think i
should be in a trial where they're in it
you can destroy him
don't talk down yourself
[Laughter]
i will tell you this right now if you go
into a match and somebody and the other
side is using a bow you better pay
attention because
let me yeah because if they're if
they're smart if they're good enough
with the bow they're good bro amy damn
the quick charger you said that every
freelance and i saw somebody on my team
with a bow i was like oh we got this
like they are savages like i don't even
know how that's done i'm like i am
rocking with you yeah i agree bold dudes
you got to worry about well it was funny
i was listening to
firing range and mark said because he
was using the lament for a while
not even as much for the poison he said
he likes to use it as a sniper so with
oath keepers you can hold it drawn so
he's got a lane
and just
let's go
and that way he's got it ready and then
they can as you said
you can switch to the like quick switch
the hand can get the one tap and they
can almost die right um but yeah it's
like oath keepers full draw it's
literally just the end of a sniper
you're just waiting to release
and
get somebody one shot he's one shot
and then you got the data because
they're ticking
as to where they are right so it's it's
it's
it's ultimate it's it's so i don't know
i don't fear much in trials but i do
fear people who are good with the
monarch and yeah i see somebody with
equipped i'm like oh i hope that they're
just flexing because most people aren't
good with it but when they are oh yes
deadly and the cleanup is so quick
oh my god you get thing that you stick
your face back it's a wrap do not you
gotta
i'm out
as soon as i get hit i'm out
on the flip side though cog if you have
somebody on your team with le monarch
that's just you know what i'm doing i'm
following that guy around and i am kill
stealing oh i'm kill stealing i'm
bringing it yeah i'm bringing the
snitches out i'm i'm dropping riffs
would you like a riff sir would you like
a real fight here's my getaway artist
would you like that too oh i'll hook
them up i'll give them the best
treatment man i'll give the best to you
all right so before we kind of get to
the end of this there's one more thing
flawless pool changes then i want to
read a couple tweets to go with them and
just kind of get the overall group stats
we're close to two hours so there's not
honestly too much else after this so
we'll kind of wrap it here no doubt no
doubt the flawless pool which we have
been enabling sunday at reset has had
has some very positive benefits it
raises overall match quality below rates
significantly and it raises the overall
win rates for solo players however
it has some drastic downsides for
players who struggle and manage to
barely go flawless it is a steep cliff
to then only play against players who
have already gone flawless that week
it also incentivizes the behavior
that is at odds with the mode and reward
system like resetting a flawless 6-win
ticket to keep getting easier matches it
also creates social friction where
players need to decide between playing
with friends or playing for awards
lastly the 10 a.m pacific on sundays is
awkward if you live anywhere but the
americas
starting tomorrow we are rolling out a
new system and leaning into weekly
performance metrics whenever you match
in trials
in addition to trying to match people
with the same number of card wins you
also attempt to match with people who
have roughly the same number of overall
wins for the weekend
if you can't find anyone to match
against it will eventually expand out to
find you a less similar match for the
pvp gods who go flawless 10 times a
weekend they will end up matching with
other players who have for example 70
plus wins on their cards
no matter how they got them
for the average team who gets a lucky
flawless in on friday or saturday on
their first card well they'll be match
against players with around seven wins
no matter how they got them
we are hoping this will give us
many of the benefits of the flawless
pool system somewhat fair matches
without the significant downsides
specifically there should be no major
inflection point where everything is
smooth prior to a win and then
everything is overly challenging
afterwards
while this does allow us to remove the
flawless pool it does have a potential
downside longer matchmaking times
yep i see they keep focusing on that i
think we think we think there's a
reasonable trade-off here between match
quality and matchmaking time average
trials matchmaking times currently sit
around 50 seconds over the next few
weekends we are going to be looking at
how much
matchmaking time goes up and if it
affects the match quality the outcomes
in all previous labs it's just numbers
uh told you guys they're leaning right
now to the 505 ones they want them to
get more to the five four five threes
as always we are going to be listening
closely to your feedback um so
that being said keep that in the back
your mind there's a couple tweets i saw
one uh triple rep
and he basically just replied to
replacing flawless pool he said how to
remove carries without saying you want
to remove carries
that's one
uh grenader jake removing any form of
replayability
um
a pvp that hinges on top tier players
carrying everyone else isn't good for
the system those are some pushbacks and
then mercury's actually had a really
good one i wanted to read as well
because even kevin allen uh one sec
[Music]
oh
no i'm still here hopefully okay i get
nervous when you don't no no no that's
fair my side
that's gonna be your new freeze moment
like whenever you freeze on stream can
we do it can we can we do that at the
end of the show can we say this has been
the last word
i gotta find his i'll look for it and
then somebody else too
but he had a good just kind of breakdown
of some things so definitely i'll see if
i can find one tweet i saw but he's
actually got a lot of replies maybe he
had a specific one but i wanted to get
you guys thoughts kind of get and this
is kind of where the whole skill base
matchmaking and this is done by again
anything but skill based matchmaking now
they're going by wins so here's the
thing take that person who played 184
matches
i don't know how many they won
per se 28
it was 28.
yeah okay he had his amount of he had
his amount of wins it was he was that's
where he got 184 that's not a lot by the
way that's not a lot
um
but on the other might be a lot
comparatively though i mean you can go
flawless four times in 28 matches you
know what i mean so
like like the thing is most people don't
play 184 win or lose no i mean so 28
wins is a lot right
yeah like i the amount i play on a
typical weekend is like seven matches so
it's like enough to go flawless and then
i log off so if i played an eighth match
the guy with 28 wins would technically
be above me right crazy that's
that's kind of so i wanted to get you
yeah so get you guys takes and that's
like a prime example of that dude who
just played a lot and occasionally
stacked up a win granted it seems like
it's going to get harder and harder
now
but again if you occasionally get you
know paired with those random people or
you know get in a jump in with a pair of
gods every so often like
the longer you play and again that's why
some of them are playing like the
replayability the long term
taking away carries is one thing i know
they're they're trying to push some of
those away but i was like oh cog what do
you what do you think on this one i'm
kind of curious as you know they're in
that spot they're in that spot again and
um
look the
the spirit of what they were trying to
do with the flawless pool i understood
but the problem is you know destiny is a
huge streaming community a huge
carry community that's part of trials
you know that's part of the allure you
know you you
some people you know who feel like hey
i'm never gonna be good i'm never gonna
go to the lighthouse match me up with
you know
whatever true vanguard fallout play all
those guys right and it's just like you
know that's a part of it and the thing
is that that part
of flawless pool does does kill that
community you know because it's going to
be a harder time it's going to be a
tougher time and
i don't know how they feel about that
because
they still going on with flawless powers
this doesn't seem to be going away you
know that's the vibe i got this this
does not seem to be going away and i
wonder if they look at it as
a vocal minority
and sometimes bungie you know they get
themselves in these positions where it's
like
you know they they say hey we look at
the data we look at the overall numbers
and we see blah blah blah it's opposite
to what these streamers are saying right
and again remember what i always said
you know when it comes to data and
analytics the problem is sometimes when
you look at things in a vacuum and
you're having success you're less likely
to change
you're less likely to change when you
have success and right now they're
having success
with population
they're having success with the without
the anti-cheat
and i don't know man i don't know i fee
trust me i feel those guys i feel murk i
feel triple i i hear where they're
coming from see mark was just kind of on
the other side i finally found a decent
one okay please i'm very curious about
what yeah so he said i think people are
really overestimating the amount of
difficulty wins are going to add up are
going to add to the experience under
approximately 30 wins or so the bell
curve is going to end up with a lot of
players under that and the matchmaking
pool won't start to narrow down on skill
until much higher win totals so like
your 70s your carries your
you know people who go flawless 20 times
in a weekend because
and that's kind of thing if more people
are kind of in this average level and if
you start you know kind of bumping out
of it the average person's gonna have a
little better time and they somebody
keeps winning and some of the high like
the more wins then the more average than
they might get a little more
it does feel like it's got some
graduality to it i think the one thing
that they did mention is that team
that happens to go flawless
right was screwed in the flawless pool
now granted they said the flawless pool
was intended to be temporary i totally
get that
um but now as i said there is no cliff
there is no like right well i got it but
now i'm totally done
so that's not gonna be a thing prothea i
want to get your thoughts on this one
just because
again pvp experience even depending on
how much time you have to play like
where do you fall in all this and where
do you think they're are they going in a
good direction
i don't know if it's a good direction
but it's definitely a direction uh i i
unders i understand um what kind of like
what cog was saying how it it could
potentially kill that community but
however there
there is a like the majority of players
playing trials probably aren't being
carried or carrying other people it's
just casual players playing and i think
that's who you really have to
cater to is those players who
aren't looking to be carried or
the small minority of people that do
carry i think majority of players are
just going into play and i think that'll
be a better experience for them and my
other thought is i remember when uh they
they nerfed aim assist on pc or whatever
and everyone was freaking out and
everyone was like oh i forgot that
happened i feel like this could be one
of these scenarios
i do i'm not going to be as i feel like
i don't think it's going to be as big as
a deal as people might think
that's that's my current theory on this
i don't think it's going to have as big
as an impact as
some of these thoughts that uh some of
these people's thoughts are having
fair enough fair enough drive yeah i'm
curious what travis uh
yeah i think i think it is a bad system
i i don't think it's a bad system for
the reason that people think that it is
though for the reason that streamers do
i think it's a bad system because people
like myself it doesn't really fix the
problem right like people like myself
who only play seven or eight matches and
then go flawless and then jump in the
same pool as them aren't playing against
the people who played 184 matches and
have 28 wins and i just don't think your
overall wins is a sign of your skill i
just think the system is is inherently
it's not balanced and it it could hurt
the streamers for sure but i think it's
all also equally likely to hurt the
people who are just playing a lot
casually and happen to have accrued a
lot of wins and it makes the it makes
your experience more likely to be not
fun the more you play in a weekend right
because if you're if you're getting wins
and not going flawless then by the end
of the weekend you're like alright well
now i'm definitely not going flawless
because i'm only playing with the people
who've been playing a lot right and i
just think that that is a problem
the second point though of like
is this bad for streamers like
are you making your game for players are
you making it for streamers really at
some point you have to kind of decide
that and i've always been on the side of
like streamers you guys are gonna be
fine you guys are gonna figure it out
you're streamers you're good at the game
you you you're you're fine and and
you're also profiting off of the game i
don't think you're in any real danger
but the casuals who drop out of the game
because your game isn't designed well or
because you're listening too much to
streamers and catering the game to them
is not how you make a a game it's not
how you build a coalition of people who
love destiny and so
um i i think they should absolutely not
build their
designs around what works for streamers
i think streamers are gonna be okay um
but that said i i think the problems
with the system have nothing to do with
that i just think amount of play time
and amount of wins does not correlate to
like a rank or skill based system and
that that this isn't a long-term
solution so let's give it a try bungie i
hope you get some good data out of it
but i don't think this is going to be
the long-term solution it's a weird
solution too right yeah it's kind of
strange
yeah it's it's similar to the way that
they were doing skill-based matchmaking
which was like overall amount of matches
played versus matches lost and stuff
like that which is just like all right
so if you play the game a lot you end up
in higher skill brackets like it just
doesn't make sense yeah which leads to
the bigger question which i completely
agree with you guys is that
you know my thing is i always go big
picture at this point why is that why
are you constantly avoiding
you know putting in the skill system
right why we we're doing we're cut you
know doing all these different things
every other thing under the sun except
that
and you might like this but it's like
technical issue
server issue
reinvestment on a bigger level to
accommodate that need and
it to me that goes back into this whole
i know you know the d3 d2 bag and you
know staying with what you have and is
it is it
something because you know
infrastructure is antiquated or you
don't mean like what is it that we're
trying everything else
other than like what apex is doing yeah
everything else other than what halo
used to do that you created that you
created you guys made that yeah right
you don't say like bungie right so that
to me i always think big picture and i i
i
again i don't i'm not don't claim to to
be a dev don't know i don't like
disrespecting dev but it's very
interesting to me
why the avoidance and
is it because long term they intend to
stay with this system and they really
can't change infrastructure stuff thus
we have things like vault dcv and other
stuff that we can't get away from
because of these constraints
that's the question for me i would love
to be a fly on the wall in those rooms
i bet the reason they don't do it cog is
because
one they're not a dedicated server game
and skill or rank based systems become
harder to manage when you're not
dedicated to servers that's what i think
i think the other the other reason is
part of part of the culture when you
have a ranked based system is people go
on sprees of losing matches on purpose
to derank themselves
and that was a big problem in the halo 2
days people would just like put
themselves in a queue and then uh you
know betrayal their own teammates for
like three hours to rank themselves down
so that they could play against people
of lower skill and just like run on
right you know just destroy them
we ran out of metals type situations
yeah yeah and i i think you have to
probably put some safeguards in there
where when somebody reaches a new
threshold they can't go
more than like one down so that they
can't like truly game the system there's
ways to do it but right um i think
there's just probably limitations and i
think the bigger issue is that they're
not that invested in in comp i mean
we've talked about that on the show a
lot but the changes they're making to
trials and this refurbishing they're all
very easy stuff to do it's like very
small changes adding matchmaking to a
game mode that sort of thing um but they
they haven't really doubled down and
said this is a pvp game and that's like
a big part of it and we're gonna build
systems to support it they've never
really taken that
um that step and i think until they do
we probably won't see any significant
changes like that so i don't want to go
to the extreme that
they don't
try to do things and things are easy i'm
not gonna go to that stream but i i do
agree with you that
they just again i gotta look at
your actions right you know that's all i
could do i could just look at your
actions your actions say otherwise your
actions say
that you know for this is the first
season i'll be honest i'm shocked that
the last three weeks we keep talking
about
we still talk about this wow okay
like i'm shocked like this is the most
pvp
i've been getting for three to four
weeks i'm almost like damn we gonna talk
about something cause it's all you
talking about is trials bungie so salute
to that right salute to that but yeah at
the end of the day it's just like
that's why i've been in that mode i know
we had our past discussions we're just
like
with this current infrastructure with
the staying with destiny 2
their their actions are showing
they don't
intend to make this the competitive game
that that's how i got to look at them
and it's up to me as a player to say hey
do i choose to stay in it and love you
for what you are with all your warts
yeah you know what i say or do i get my
competitive fix elsewhere and i've i've
made that decision honestly since like
i don't know shadow keep you know like
shadow keep it wasn't like no maps
coming
it was like we've been you know
it's the father and now the neglected
father child relationship you know it's
just i've always like but now you're
spending time with us she coming every
weekend you're dropping a gift off with
a little toy here with a trials thing
here
um what you got okay go ahead and
they're really curious when they're just
gonna be like
trials is good right now and then go to
com
when's the last time they're like yes
that we we think we've landed in a good
spot and people are going to be like
really yeah
because it sounds like they want to go
from like really focused on trials and
they said iron banner is kind of like
the next step and then the comp playlist
is down the road i'm just really curious
when they're gonna be like okay we think
trials is okay right now it's time to
move on to the next thing
will that ever happen
i don't know yeah i was like for that
blog post i think it would be fun no
block trials
travis's face on that blah blah you know
what guys we did it
i want to see his face for that one
no yeah tech actually nice we made it
oh yeah i'm sorry big else tonight yeah
isp doing this tonight for me
i'm imagining guns i'm imagining it's
like the last word guns not the elves
because he was like
said uh basically the way i'm writing
these changes i shouldn't even attempt
trials until as late as possible let the
rest of the players weed themselves out
of my wind bracket he said bungie needs
to make people excited and want to play
trials as much as possible this isn't it
and then for travis you'll appreciate
this one true vanguard it's looking like
bungie's vision for trials is that it
will be an activity for players to
engage with until they get their loot
hang out for a little bit and then dip
which if that's their goal for this mode
that's fine but bungie absolutely needs
to make good on their promise to make
standard pvp a real priority with new
maps and game modes and a competitive
overhaul we have something to go back to
when we're done with trials that's still
worth engaging with just my two cents
yeah
100 true vanguard is correct like if if
trials is going to be casual that's fine
i've never been like a elitist about
trials being the mode and it has to be a
a walled garden or whatever it's just
that i want there to be a competitive
mode and i think
cog hopefully what they're doing right
now is they're just experimenting and
they're getting ready for a proper
overhaul ads
some of the infrastructure that they
would need to make comp real and i think
part of that would probably be moving
over to dedicated servers finally and
also uh and also uh having some sort of
ranking system involved but i don't i
don't know if they're going to do that i
think for now they're having fun and
they're experimenting and all that i
think that's better than nothing which
is yeah absolutely absolutely yeah
absolutely but
um yeah i i
i tend to agree that this is not the
solution right yeah these are these are
these are the half measures and
experimentation phase
and you know i'm just like
we'll see we'll we'll see where it goes
you know if if we get jesus
right now
cogs exactly exactly
they're still ahead of new world right
now because man there was a bug that
dropped today
yeah so
they were messing with the wars and
there's a bunch of lag going on well
whatever they did there was some stuff
they took the like there's a healing
circle you can stand in to have healing
tick over time well if you t bag the
healing circle it ins it like refills
your life as fast as you can like
basically go up and like squat and stay
it's like
pink
finally in-game benefits for what i've
been doing yeah finally yeah bungie
has finally taught me everything i need
to know about gaming
exactly
well as my connection is trying to shoot
itself in the face i am sorry for the
stream tonight everybody hopefully the
video uploads those will be smooth
whenever they get uploaded because i
don't even know what my upload speed is
like
i think that's pretty much where we can
that kind of covers everything for the
week is there anything else you guys
wanted to touch on um prothean
especially is there anything else cog
what were you going to say no real quick
i was going to say shout out to the new
uh community manager i believe yes um
yeah yeah lyanna that was that was
enough
dirty f and hippie is her twitter handle
so
go follow her
yeah i saw some mentions
i was very honored and humbled to see
you know thai guy e you know we got a
little mention people like yo y'all need
to go check out the last word
they were directing her to here and i
thought that was really cool to see
people because i think she put out a
tweet like kind of hey who's you know
who you guys feel should be bigger and
more you know deserving and i saw a lot
of the community do that so shout out to
everybody yeah know this person
liana does she work for ign
i know lyanna i'm already i was like
okay i'm already following her so i must
know her somehow because i don't really
follow that many people connections how
do i know this person connection that's
crazy let's go hollywood oh she works
she works for game informer that's all
right okay that's what it is oh yeah cbs
which was yeah cbs as well yeah i think
it's awesome that they have another
community manager on the team i mean
it's a huge community so no doubt people
on that team is yeah good yes huge huge
good good day good luck besides
cosmo needs somebody else to go into the
reddit posts and deliver the bad news
from them yeah exactly exactly cosmo
dude i swear they give him the bad stuff
yes he's yeah
he gets the funnel he's the vanguard yep
um
step in front of the front of the army
well
protheon it has been a pleasure for
having you i'm so sorry my isp is made
streaming not the greatest but people
will be finding this thing fill their
audio holes and you know their eyeballs
audio holes ears
this guy's from a different planet
no the secret's out
i'm an invader
uh no but as people come across this one
uh best thing is let people know where
to find you let people know where to
send their tank memes um all the good
things that can come your way
uh the floor is yours basically anything
you got going on where to find what you
do all that stuff let them know
yes you could find me on twitter at
prothean underscore because
the at prothean account is by some
russian dude who has not used the
account since 2015. don't you hate and
has tweeted seven things love it um so i
haven't gotten
the actual proteon account so it's
protheon underscore
and you can also find me on twitch i've
been starting to stream more often you
can find me um x protheon uh twitch.tv
slash xprotheon uh
no i tried to
i want like x protheon to be like a more
mainstream thing
actually probably someone does have
protheon so
sure we'll say yeah yeah so those are
the two places you could find me
no doubt no doubt man salute to you man
again like i said love you came on and
um oh she's very fortunate i got a
chance to play through matchmaking which
is fun you know that was cool and i
didn't get a chance to talk much about
you know the poorly timed game stuff and
and being this you know social media
manager there and i just think it's cool
you know to see people keep expanding in
the community and you're very respected
out here dusty tracker we've been using
it for a while always you know you know
get over there get my info so thank you
man thank you for coming on in thanks
for waiting five ten minutes for my late
self
i don't believe that tardy
so bad i felt vows like damn i wanted to
get the first bad impression of the cog
this way
right now
30 minutes late he's just like whatever
guys i'm the star you play every guy
yeah
talking that you're talking that twist
about the water bottle talking yeah
i want to give you the worst i'm going
to give you the worst reputation in the
industry any time it's like working with
[ __ ] i'll be like oh my god dude he's so
verbally and physically abuses us like
he's just terrible
how does he physically he literally
hires people sends them to my house and
it's a delivery punch
yeah you know what he yells us out for
if we look him in the eyes he doesn't
like that he says you would need to look
below my line outside oh the level okay
stare at my chest
i see we do it
on my chest
y'all savages anyways
thank you very much for having me on um
i mean you and i have been friends i'd
say for a few years now honestly um
i love the last word podcast uh trav i
talked to you a little before the show i
listened to fire team chat all the time
uh big fan of your work so uh it was
honored dude i'm honored to be on here
with you guys it was great talking with
you seriously
it's our pleasure man we always enjoyed
yeah you know anybody in the community
and it's just it's awesome to see like
as you said we've been talking off and
on a little bit here and there for years
to see you now community manager for
games and working with destiny tracker
and just kind of doing stuff that seems
like a passion for you it just seems
natural and fit so
i'm glad to see the prothean meme turned
into a career which you can't ask for
anything better than that so that's kind
of amazing
that's great i i really love that uh
scrappy origin story yeah yeah it was
great meeting you um and glad that you i
liked fire team chat i also really liked
that show um i look forward to your next
episode in february
yeah yeah or is it going to be december
do you think you'll do one for gala
we'll see we'll see i would like us to
do it more often but you know dustin
every time i hit him up about a podcast
now he's like i don't have time
for time
he's locked unlocked on that side he's
like then he's like i don't have time
for you
yeah it was great meeting you prothean
uh you know who you remind me of you
look like um oh you look like one of the
ron weasley brothers you know his his
gang you look have you ever gotten that
has anybody told you you look like
you're like related to ron weasley a
little bit
i've gotten that i've gotten um rick
astley i've
what else you got
uh cameron the guy who plays calcus and
phone and star wars phone order camera
i think i remember you tweeting that or
something almost maybe like i feel like
yeah
yeah at 10 000 followers i said i'll do
whatever the top comment says and the
top comment was a calcus cosplay so i
actually had one of my friends make a
the
poncho that he wore and i uploaded a
picture on twitter and everyone's like
oh my god it really is calculus so yeah
ron weasley calcus rick astley all the
above nice check that's me
nice good good yeah it's nice to meet
you uh you can find me on twitter at
thai guy travis i don't have an
underscore
gotcha russians
um and uh yeah you can uh
because we got to deal with travis and
his remarks
they come for your usernames first then
they attack your isp you gotta you gotta
get out ahead of them guys uh
we need to fight back
um
yeah you can find my articles previews
and reviews on ign.com this week i will
actually not this week on early next
week i'll have my review of writer's
republic up uh for you to take a look at
i'm enjoying it so far though um if
you're into extreme sports games it's
very forza horizon-esque um and then you
can all you can also in addition to
watching this show which i will promote
on this show
the last word tell your friends guys
talk to them talk today if you're
watching tell your friends next next
episode i want you to bring here's your
homework assignment bring one other
person into the stream people watch the
show with you and comment with them and
introduce us to them look at that look
at that eight plus chromebooks
love that man that's what i'm talking
about don't be afraid
don't be afraid to be great
yeah don't forget to fight back against
russia and uh also you can uh you can
watch me on
bitcast on sundays at 8 a.m pacific
although this week we are actually doing
our show on saturday night instead
because we're doing a halloween episode
where we're all going to be in costume
video game characters so get ready for
that um i'm very excited uh that's uh
tomorrow night so i'll be back tomorrow
night to do it i was waiting for some
damn slander i
was coming i thought dance landed was
coming
i was gonna get there and you can also
uh you can watch me and my friend aims
and this other guy who's the last living
descendant of bigfoot
is there as well so yeah right good
times
good time
what do you got going on cog yeah i
gotta let dad hear these this landed you
be giving him is so elaborate i'm gonna
make a compilation of all this yeah
i said that the one that you called him
a wizard i lost it that was the funniest
ever yeah hopelessly i love that joke oh
yeah
oh definitely uh definitely duke he had
a cool one um did a mailbag a second
mail bag which was fun kind of like a
ass [ __ ] ass [ __ ] anything people asked
the wildest questions i had fun though
it was a little bit you used a bidet yet
um no and i refuse
[Laughter]
they own me they own me they don't like
that i'm anti tv day but um if you want
multiple
i would at least try it once that's all
i'm saying like it might be weird but
it'd be like will you try this one time
sure
just give me some paper towel in case
speaking of ivantas would try a lot of
stuff one time oh my god
moving
ultimate again on that episode you're
savage um if you want bidet like stories
we do have a funny one on defining dude
that we just recorded with via baddie
talking about worse situations where you
have to go to the bathroom it is it was
a random fan writing question during the
show
absolutely
maddie's story is the funniest thing
i've ever heard please listen to that
episode just for the story alone and if
not just wait till sunday it'd be free
99 on on sunday so if you don't want to
pay for the people don't promote the
free version
communist russia listen we're back on
russia again tom's is tough out here not
everybody got that picture
so catch me that obviously iop this
sunday 11 a.m eastern with the lords we
will have the legendary daddy pena will
pull up very quickly
that's all he just got on g4 so yeah got
a g4 we're gonna talk about that the
gamertag radio days all the fun stuff
and of course to ease dismay we gotta
promote that last word podcast salute
gotta promote it man got it but make
sure you tell your friends like travis
said eloquently if you're here i'm okay
with that i'm okay are you okay with
that are you okay with you you're just
like oh this is the best pog you're
literally listening to it tell your
friends that's a new twist i like this
oh that's a new twist are you like
hey tell your friends do your homework
bring a buddy send in the link drop a
like drop a review on itunes
subscribe to the channel all that stuff
every week when we get to the spark [ __ ]
tell them to not tell their friends
don't tell your friends don't tell them
the first
in the world of streaming and game
playing and what's going on man uh so
yeah kind of trying to find a time to
start guardians of the galaxy working on
a little bit of content stuff in between
and i think more than anything trying to
figure what's up with my isp but it's
like i've had techs out they were
literally like checked and confirmed
i've had them again oh i had newbie tech
monday morning oh dude
did you reboot the router no no not even
that we got to the point wheels like go
out to the tap outside and check didn't
know how to test the throughput speed on
his tool
i'm like what are you doing here because
this is literally why you're here
cause the speeds are slow so he was on
like week two he's like every job i go
to like this thing doesn't work i'm like
you need to figure this out call
somebody that sentence bad say yeah your
first sentence is every job i go to
yeah
you're the tech or the assignment you
know the best part was
we like my political speed is supposed
to be 40. right now it's probably
.0008 which is fine it sucks yeah but
because i literally watched it drop
while i was saying that sentence
yeah
yeah because i'm sure it may sound weird
too yeah yeah but
the idea is
my download is like 900 plus ish
whatever i pay for my upload speed is
40.
this dude had the audacity and whoever
he talked to on the phone was like he
saw 28 on a speed test somewhere and
he's like oh yeah that's our highest i'm
like no it's not he's like yeah i'm like
take a second i know you're new
talk go call a supervisor and check
walked outside came back inside yeah i'm
wrong i'm like i know
i'm like i know you are it's like i've
had more people out here i have a
supervisor's cell phone number that i
can literally like and she's actually
she deserves like a raise like
but no that was like i was like i got
newbie guys like oh god this is more
useless but they did that maintenance is
still in there it's like i've gotta
take it in and stuff like that i found
your next day job
what fixing the internet
you're gonna replace this guy
it's not
no i'm sorry like
i've been on
different jobs different levels of all
things
that's one of those things when a
customer says no i know this is what i
pay for you better know your stuff or
you better shut up and ask like
that's a really good way to get a bad
review i'm like they sent the survey
review i wasn't going to do it because
that kid is new and i'm sure he's just
happy to have a job but that's not how
you do it
so
i agree so yeah fix my internet
hopefully um other than that just kind
of hold down the fort down here and
try and get things a little squared away
so for me for you guys thank you again
protheon this was a longer episode i
don't know if i didn't even ask time
frames hopefully we didn't overstate
you're welcome but thank you
um no problem yeah so thank you for very
much joining us tonight it was an
absolute pleasure to be joined by the
strike boss the tank master and of
course
community manager of all things um
destiny and uh poorly timed games
so for this episode of ue
these two all the hard times i get it's
so much fun
ah
it's good times though wouldn't wouldn't
get the hard times from anybody else
though gotta be gotta be family to give
each other a hard time right
exactly so for episode number 171 slowly
clawing our way up to 200.
thank you guys very much protheon thank
you travis thank you cognito thank you
all in chat as well who survived through
the horrible connections hopefully if
you guys listen to this it's a smooth
upload or audio wherever you find this
thing but for this episode we're gonna
wrap it up so it has been